how many Best Picture Oscar winners can
you name starting in 1990 all the way
through today I'll give you one hint
um there are 33 33 Okay uh let's let's
start with with most recent Coda we'll
go back we'll do parasite we'll do Nomad
land spotlight
um 12 Years a Slave God the daughters
uh let's go to Titanic Let's go to
um Argo
uh
uh oh man I'm feeling miserably at this
and I call myself the awards Ace this is
a problem
okay so I'm thinking obviously okay what
should have won I can tell you right now
just doing this list and what already
annoys me that I'm doing this that I'm
thinking that this social network did
not win best picture and for that the
whole thing just makes me just want to
die I mean this is you're talking about
a film in my estimation it's perfect so
when you when you watch The Social
Network and you find out the King speech
won best picture over it that just makes
me Furious
why do you think that is
because there's so few films that we see
that are
truly spectacular across the board
really exemplary in every single aspect
and when you watch The Social Network
you're looking at a film that obviously
Direction screenplay cinematography
score the resin raw score is is I think
that's the cherry on top that's what
makes that film the true Masterpiece
that it is is that it's the choices that
resner Ross did in that score from that
opening scene when he's walking across
Harvard Square you say oh my God this is
unique and this was not a choice that
most composers would do and and the fact
that Fincher allowed them to work in
that space and create something again if
you give that to any other composing Duo
composer singular you're talking about a
different film because they're not going
to come up with that score and I think
that is really what cements that as a
masterpiece but performances everything
in that film is is perfection and the
fact that it didn't win best picture is
again just I think it's got to be the
biggest crime in the history of the
Oscars the fact that it did not win best
picture
and then The King's Speech what is it
about that film or it maybe it's nothing
it's just in comparison it's that's what
it is it's not about it's not about The
King's Speech it's about selecting for
me it's it's it's really about
identifying what's the best film what is
the best film that we saw this year that
hits everything that you're looking for
and I think when I watch a film and I
try to say more of a film evaluator than
a film critic you look at it and you say
what are the aspects that shine here
what what is truly worthy of
spotlighting this for an awards purposes
and when you watch a film like again
social network you you see it in every
single category you're looking for
literally everything even production
design uh which is lower down the list
for that film but it's still creates a
world which is very hard to do
um and I think that's one of the key
components for for any film is World
building and that is production design
and I think that when you when you have
a film that hits everything and it it
doesn't win that's what that's the hard
part that's the thing for me it's like
yeah it's at the end of the day it's
just a trophy that says you're the best
film doesn't mean it is but it should
have been that film that year and that's
what I think it is it's not about King
speech it's about social network being
truly Perfection well it's public
acknowledgment too and and
acknowledgment of a group of sort of
Gatekeepers that say okay you're worthy
and so 2011 King's Speech did you know
going in there's no way the social
Network's going to win no I thought for
sure listen at the end of the day you
you still have hope they're going to
pick the right the number one film right
and yours might be different but overall
when you look at in your you know you
watch
hundreds of films a year and you see the
one that is very clearly the best film I
mean I go back obviously they got it
right with parasite another film that is
True Perfection occasionally uh they are
going to miss it's just going to happen
it's just the law of averages are going
to say that it's going to go to
something else I mean this year I
wouldn't have pakota uh uh for sure
um I mean I think I think Coda is is a
very likable film do I think that it
holds up to the you know when we look
back at Oscar's 2022 are we going to say
Coda is filmmaking that is truly gonna
you know pass the test of time I don't
think so I think it's a it's a likable
film but I just don't think it hits
again when I watch a film for me it's
really technical it's so important to a
film the tech for me is where I really
get dialed in like when I watch the
Batman I mean I see Matt Reeves and I
say this is a director when I go back
and I watch let me in you just know that
this is a a person that has a skill that
is extremely unique and they have a
vision that is singular and those are
the things that for me as I'm assessing
you know Awards value for a film those
are the films that you want to see
succeed
so a director like Ty West who's
creative and edgy
will he ever receive an Oscar not for X
I mean he's not he's not going to win
for x uh but when you watch and I go
back and I remember innkeepers from Thai
West and I don't remember thinking too
much of that film or the direction but
whatever happened between innkeepers
roughly a decade ago and X I mean X is
when you watch that film you are looking
at a director who has again that skill
that is and the artistic Vision that
most people don't possess and it's it
could be a traditional remake of Texas
Chainsaw Massacre right and it's not it
is it's got so many layers to it and I
think the choices the landslide scene in
X
um you know the Fleetwood Mac I mean
that is truly when you watch that film
the way it's edited the way it
organically flows from the film uh and
just all of a sudden he starts on the
guitar and it starts into the Montage of
through the years it is that is the best
sequence that I have seen in several
years as a singular sequence of a film
the landslide sequence in x uh do I hope
Thai West will be a Best Director one
day absolutely and I think he no
question he possesses the skill that
he's been working in the horror realm
let's hope I know he's got Pearl coming
up later this year they shot him back to
back right they shot the prequel and
during well they shot X so Pearl's
coming out this fall and I can't wait to
see that as well but he's someone that's
on the radar as somebody who you know
going forward I would not be surprised
if this is somewhere we're talking about
in the in the ventures in the Nolans you
know the full news when we get up to
that top level tie West is absolutely
going to be there one day sure sure and
he's still very young oh yeah
he's probably his late 20s 30s but he's
got such a I think that's when you watch
a film when I go to see films you're
really looking for that that talent that
pops and you say wow this is again
remarkable skill and singular vision in
that the average person you know you see
so many films and you see decent
Direction you see above average
Direction and then you see what Tai West
did next
um or David Fincher in Social Network or
any number of films obviously from
Fincher but when you get to those that
that level of skill is is uh that's the
tree that's the Cinematic treat that
we're all looking for
so 1990 Driving Miss Daisy 1991 Dances
with Wolves 92 Silence of the Lambs 93
Unforgiven 94 Schindler's List 95
Forrest Gump 96 Braveheart 97 The
English Patient 98 Titanic 99
Shakespeare in Love 2 000 American
Beauty 2001 Gladiator 2002 A Beautiful
Mind 2003 Chicago 2004 the Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King 2005 one of
my favorites excuse me a Million Dollar
Baby
2006 another favorite crash 2007 The
Departed 2008 No Country for Old Men
2009 Slumdog Millionaire 2010.
oh I've got loved anymore yes you do
love to eat when we have yes yeah you
can keep okay
oh my God yeah okay all right so we're
paying homage today on 2010 Hurt Locker
2011 The King's Speech 2012 artist 2013
Argo 2014 12 Years a Slave 2015 Birdman
yes I like Birdman 2016 Spotlight
yeah 2017 Moonlight 2018 the shape of
water 2019 green book 2020 parasite
2021 Nomad land
Coda okay
okay I mean overall when you when you
list off the when we go back to 1990 you
look at those films I there's not a
whole there's not a film in there that I
say wow this is not
worthy of being best picture I don't see
there's not one even crash I mean listen
I'm not suggesting the crash is is the
all-time best movie ever made but I
understand
how people respond to the film I think
that's one of the things that you have
to be able to do when you go in and you
critique a film or evaluate a film is
you're trying to for me is figure out
what is the audience for this film and
do you understand how this audience for
the film will be able or will not be
able to embrace this film and I think
that when you watch a film
um like top gun Maverick you you see it
I saw it you know three weeks ago before
it opened and I said this is a film that
will be loved by 99 of the people that
see it 99 because it is that it's it
gives you everything that you want for a
movie-going experience for the average
moviegoer right
um understand the spectrum of moviegoers
is extremely wide and and but at the end
of the day when you're talking about a
film that's going to appeal to a large
swath of the movie going public you have
to identify something like topical
Maverick is going to work and it did I
said it's going to get an eight plus
Cinema score it did which means perfect
word of mouth right that means people
are going out of top gun Maverick and
they're saying you have to see this film
which doesn't happen very often that
that true organic love for a film that
spreads like wildfire because everybody
who goes to see it comes run out and
they become an apostle like hey you
gotta go see top gun Maverick and that's
what's happening and I think when you
look back at from 1990 on to most of
those films most of those films have
that even Coda which I said I have
plenty of issues with from a filmmaking
perspective it still has that aspect of
Word of Mouth being strong where people
say oh I really liked Coda and you need
to have that because that's in King's
speeches that way uh so you understand
how that happened people like the feel
that The King's Speech gives you
conversely I understand how the social
network is not an uplifting film but it
doesn't have to be like there's no law
that says films have to be uplifting one
of the things I love about a film from
the past uh two plus decades up in the
air is the fact that it isn't a a
buttoned up ending in bow tie and
everybody he gets the girl that's what
makes up in the air the film it is same
with La La Land exact same thing is that
that's what makes the the film what it
is is the fact that it's not a perfect
finish to a film but some audience
people members do not like that they
want they want to have they want to go
home feeling good and so I think that's
that will that's why people don't like
La La Land as much or Up In The Air I
remember my ex-wife at the time was like
I hate it up for the air why you didn't
get the girl I'm like that's why it's
good that's exactly why it's good
where did you see the first Top Gun
once a while yeah I was I was uh you
know an 80s kid and Top Gun came out and
it was listen you go back to the 80s and
you know I mean listen we grew up a
similar era and and you you say to
yourself uh what a difference it was
back then right because back then it was
just you didn't you had three networks
okay and PBS we didn't even have Fox at
that time you had television you had a
radio that was it right and you had
movies and you went to a movie and
that's all you had so you had this just
everyone would talk about one thing
which we don't have as much anymore
these days because there's so many
choices to which you can spend your free
time on your entertainment time on back
then it was movies network television or
radio and when we would go to the movies
and I sold Top Gun and uh it just you
know I was a young kid growing up I'm
like I want to be like Maverick I want
to be that guy and uh you know this the
soundtrack okay we all had the cassette
not the CD CDs right around not the
vinyl although I had vinyl didn't have
the vinyl that had the cassette wore it
out CBS records I remember going
backwards and forwards backwards and
forwards on that thing because in the
old days for those who don't remember
the the cassettes were pain in the butt
to go for the next song you had to fast
forward and then hit it perfectly at the
right time but but that film was a
phenomenon I mean it was what everybody
was talking about Top Gun was the thing
I remember being uh in high school and
they had the Top Gun uh we had like
assembly and and the cheerleaders went
out there and danced to like two
different songs from Top Gun it's like
that's how it was a phenomenon right and
it's hard to find that these days and I
think that's the magic of of 80s of of
Top Gun or any real major film in the
80s go back and look at the Lost Boys
boys
um you know these are films that that
really shaped who I am and I we had so
many great films in the 80s I mean I I
saw all these films in theaters too you
go back to E.T Empire Strikes Back
Return of the Jedi aliens uh cocktail my
God uh cocktail for his as absolutely
fluffy forgettable as it is it is a film
that I love it's one of those guilty
pleasures right and there's so many of
those in the 80s
um but I mean The Lost Boys was a film
that I saw and I said wow this is cool I
just love that's a film that is if you
had 20 best films I've ever seen Lost
Boys is on the list even Vision Quest
and I'm not a wrestling fan but there
was something about that opening with
the Journey song and that they're the
bus and and it got you excited and and I
feel like some of that's lost these days
but you know you say that it's funny
like you cocktail the beginning of
cocktail like you said the beginning of
the Starship song that he gets on the
bus and he's going off to New York to be
this uh big famous business guy
um is you remember those things and like
you said there's just something about
about the way 80s films were made and I
think that's what you when you watch top
gun Maverick you see that right when you
see what Kaczynski did at the beginning
of that film with the intro with the Top
Gun theme bleeding into danger zone it's
that's an 80s start right it's just
here's your here's your credit scene
your your beginning credit scene which
you don't usually get in film these days
and it was such a smart move and I think
that sets you up for everything it
delivers but the 80s were I mean uh
again I you could list a zillion movies
even going back to the you know garbage
slasher films these are all the things
that got me into film sure and All the
Right Moves oh God yeah yeah oh yeah I
mean the diversity right the diversity
no the diversity of all the films that
that we had in the 80s uh just it was
just anything goes and I think that
um you know some people devalue 80s
films and say their forgettable fluff
they're this and that
um but but I think of so many I mean one
of my favorite comedies of all time is
Real Genius with Val Kilmer I mean the
character that Val Kilmer is in Real
Genius reminds me a lot I often wonder
did Ryan Reynolds watch Real Genius
because his Persona and I love Ryan
Reynolds I think he's great he's very
good at that sarcastic snarky guy uh
very quick-witted you go back and watch
Val Kilmer in Real Genius you're like
that is very much like what Ryan
Reynolds is these days I think Val
Kilmer in top secret same thing he's
just Val Kilmer is such an underrated
actor I think we're all me to round to
that now with top gun Maverick and
seeing him in the film and and certainly
the documentary from last year uh but
you know Real Genius is just uh what a
great comedy I could I've watched that
film probably 30 times
do you see the same quality movie from
the 1990s winners to today's winners I
mean
I think we are in a space where uh you
look at some of the films people always
say this would would we have the same
films made today that we did back in the
90s or the 80s and I think that the
answer to that is I don't think all of
them would I don't think that we would
see some of those films made today but I
think right now is such an interesting
time because you have a film in theaters
right now that is very much of an 80s 90
Revival and that is top gun Maverick
again and when you look at top gun
Maverick it's absolutely the reason it's
connecting is because it it doesn't feel
nothing in the film feels forced it
feels like it is organic and I think
that is one thing that has to be part of
your film no matter what you're doing
you have to make it feel like everything
in the film is there for a reason and is
not and absolutely wedged in because it
has to be okay and that there's many
different definitions for what that is
but I think that when I watch top gun
Maverick I see a hearkening back to this
we're just going to make a good film and
we're not going to think so much about
what has to be in or what doesn't have
to be and we're just going to make the
film that we want to make
um and I think that that that's a that's
a thing that Studios have a challenge
with I think a lot of studios are are
have issues doing nothing Paramount has
really nailed the fact that they just
make films that are very likable uh and
they they look at what they've had this
year they've had scream did very well
for them jackass forever not a fan of
the series but still successful film uh
lost city was good for them Sonic too
they and even Clifford the the Big Red
Dog movie was actually somehow
entertaining I couldn't believe it but
Paramount is doing the right thing right
now and now attack on Maverick they
whoever's running that the creatives
there are in the right great space I
think for making a movie that appeals to
a wide audience and and we need that we
need to have films that appeal to that
huge part of the movie going pie because
that in turn will flow down to some of
these smaller films because the Studios
have more people going to film so
they're going to have more money they're
going to spend more money on product
because obviously film cinema is back
okay so when we were back in 2020 we all
know people were saying our movie's ever
going to come back are people going to
go to the movies do they feel safe and
and there were a lot of people that said
I don't know if it's ever going to come
back I don't think this is this might be
done and I was like no this isn't done I
mean theaters are are Cathedrals there
are you know houses of worship for
Cinema and for me again going back
decades it's a place that I go to Just
escape the world right and get locked in
to a film for an hour and a half two
hours and you are just there you're lost
you're not thinking about anything else
and you know sometimes Studios will send
me a screening link say hey do you want
to watch this at home I'm like no I
don't because I get distracted you put
it on and then you get a text you get
bored you grab your phone when you're at
a theater your full attention is there
right you made the effort to come to the
theater to watch this film and there's
something magical about that being
locked in that experience cannot be
replicated at home you know it's just
it's impossible because the distractions
will enter in and it's just and also the
communal aspect of it right the communal
aspect of film in in ingesting a film as
it were is is really when you watch it
with it with an audience you say to
yourself uh you you all experience these
emotions at the same time which again is
so rare as we talked about earlier about
that that everyone's doing one thing
that we all grew up in the 80s where it
was only this and this now we've got so
many different options that we rarely
have that opportunity to come together
and experience one thing at one time and
and that's the magic of movie going and
I think that's why it's not going away
and it's great to see it back because
it's it's back I mean you look at all
these films that have done well over the
last few months starting obviously today
with top gun Maverick going back to
everything everywhere all at once that's
over 50 million domestic for a small
independent film uh that is back to 2019
levels and I think that it's absolutely
should be encouraging for everybody
because we need it we need films you
know like Nicole Kidman says but forgive
me I have not seen top gun Maverick yet
but does it try to be an 80s film or
does not it it lets itself be current
I think it does a great job Maverick
does a top gun Maverick does a really
good job of being a little bit of both
being an 80s film
um late 80s film and then into what we
have today again I think the magic of
the film for me and how that film really
works is that it is so spiritually
connected to the original it has so much
love for the predecessor that I was
shocked when I watched the film that it
was so connected organically to it
without it feeling forced and I think
these days you you see so many things
that feel like again we're gonna
absolutely impart this in here and it's
whether we're just gonna do it and it
might not serve the story it might not
be organic grounded in in the original
and Maverick finds a way to do that and
to couple it to the original that makes
it
um again this is why everyone loves the
film because it really is able to do
that and I think people do respond to
when things are grounded and they are
organic versus they are forced I mean
it's just that's that's what what we
know we have that internal judge that
goes and go that person is full of BS or
that person is authentic and I think the
film feels authentic and if your film
doesn't feel authentic and it feels like
parts of it have been uh or
inorganically altered as it were then
you're going to notice that and it's not
going to resonate with you as fully as
it would is if it feels like it is all
in service of the story and it works as
a whole for the complete film and your
moviegoing experience when you left the
theater where other people just as
excited oh God yeah I mean when I came
out of Matt we sold press screening two
and a half weeks before it came out and
uh I have not I've been hundreds of
press screenings and you know when you
have something special
um you know when everybody's on the same
page when they come out and they're all
like oh my god oh did you you know
everyone has the little conversation
outside what'd you think of the film and
I try not to say too much because I one
thing that's interesting when you come
out of a film I I almost want to hold my
reaction and not tell anybody because I
don't want to be tainted by anyone
else's opinion so I try to stay away
from what other people say until I have
a chance to see it because we all will
be if you if you listen to enough people
say this movie is the best movie ever
made and then you go into a thinking
that then of course your expectations
are high and then the film ends up being
a little under the best movie ever made
and then you are you know you've been
affected by the by the the words that
you've heard but top gun Maverick was
was one of those films you come out of
and you just knew when the critics are
all on the same page when virtually
everybody it's like this is really a
grand slam of a film then you know
you're in something special and when you
have those you have that happen from
time to time in screenings I mean I'm
gonna go back one of the screenings I'll
never forget was in Boston for uh the
raid the raid is is really truly the
Raid Redemption is is one of my favorite
is probably the best action film of all
time I think really if you look at that
film and I remember sitting in that
press screen in Boston with a bunch of
my buddies there's is lightly 10
probably 25 of us in this gigantic
theater and I've never experienced a
film where people are getting out of
their seats and shouting right it has so
much just emotional punch in
testosterone just flowing throughout
that film uh that I never will forget
that moment and I go back to the raid
and I just it's one of those that's
again cinematic experience I'll never
forget I would not have had if I watched
a screener at home wouldn't have been
anywhere near the same
how do you judge a movie what's your
rating system it is really when I look
at a film and I'm watching it I'm
evaluating film and I'm determining
is it accomplishing what it's setting
out to accomplish so what is the mission
of the film what what is the filmmaker
trying to do with this film you know
when you watch a film like hereditary
what ariaster is trying to do with that
film is much different than what uh
kaczynski's doing with with top gun
Maverick they're they're but but yet so
you're judging them in ultimately what
were they trying to do with this story
okay and did they deliver it in the way
that in the best possible way that that
they were capable of doing and I think
that it's it's one of those things when
you you just you have to you obviously
have to see a lot of films to know what
what is what is of a good quality of an
excellent quality and then an absolutely
you know otherworldly Stratosphere
equality you need to see plenty of films
to get to that point but but those are
rare but I think that you're ultimately
just trying to figure out
what is the director trying to do here
and did they do it with Maximum Impact
and top gun Maverick is stratospheric
absolutely yeah I mean I mean just
because of because it delivers what it
was intending to do and does it above
even that level so you're expecting the
sequel that's kind of just there right
it's it's it's a sequel we see so many
sequels that are just kind of
unnecessary right they make it and it's
just a money grab and there's no real uh
emotional value to it and I think that
this film where people are resonating
why it's doing the the business that's
doing it's going to continue to do over
the next several weeks months and years
is that it gives you all of those pieces
that you're looking for and and that is
rare that that it's able to do that
especially in the sequel it's very
difficult to do
um but but when you watch a film I think
ultimately for me when I when I'm out
evaluating a film and I'm watching it
um you never want to dislike a film ever
you want to like a film I I don't drive
across town to Century City to watch to
Beverly Hills to to the fox lot to Santa
Monica you don't drive all those places
in rush hour traffic to go watch a film
and go this is terrible you don't want
to do that you want to like everything I
think a lot of people think that we you
go in and say ah no they they wanted to
hate this film just saw Crimes of the
future I wanted to like it I love
Cronenberg but this is a film that feels
flat this is a film that is going to be
for extremely narrow uh audience it's
just it's not and it it's just a doll
film and I think that I wanted to like
it but but you don't ever go in wanting
to dislike a film it just happens right
so you try to remain as detached as
possible and I think one thing that's
very important when you when you're
watching a film if you love a director
let's say that I'm going to see the next
safety brother films and I mean good
time is one of my favorite films of the
past decade easy I mean that is just
absolutely gangbusters everything about
that film is just uh but if I see the
next after Brothers film I'm going to
try to get all that out of my head and
I'm gonna say what are we doing here
um it's not
obviously entirely possible to get rid
of all of the the Goodwill that you had
from before but you've got to try to go
in there as much as possible with a
blank slate so that you don't become
like oh this is the safety brothers so
that means that I'm gonna have to love
this or it's gonna be great it doesn't
mean that we see plenty of directors
that have maybe their best film as their
first film right and they go down then
we have directors who go up there we
have some of the plateau whatever that
is
um every film has to be evaluated on its
own not as part of a legacy of a
director or an actor or a studio or a
distributor or any of these things you
have to just go in there and be as
unbiased as possible
and I did for some for some people it's
it's difficult I think it is I think
it's uh that you you it's hard to fight
that I want to like this film
um or you know I I know this is going to
be good or I know this can be bad
there's some people that go in like that
you have to be as down the middle as
possible when you go to see these films
and I think that ultimately the people
that resonate with you that they they
listen to you or they read your reviews
or they they listen to your words about
any given film they know that you are a
Fair Critic and you're not biased you
are not trying to uh impart your own
you're trying to just judge this film on
its own individual merits period right
regardless of who the director is
regardless of the actors involved the
studio it's all about just that singular
film and what is on the screen
how much do you think the original
actors being in the sequel contributes
to the public loving the film
you have to I mean other than Kelly
McGillis right who's not in this you I
think it's it's important to bring that
you have to have obviously those
original characters you don't want to
recast all those or not bring some of
them back I mean you in Top Gun Maverick
you brought almost everybody back right
you have Cruz uh Kilmer comes back sorry
if that's a if that's a spoiler uh it's
out there I think everyone knows that by
now uh Miles Teller does a great job as
Goose's son obviously Anthony Edwards
does not come back
um but but when you look at that that
film it's it's the characters are there
that you know so you already go in there
with familiarity which is not uh
something to be taken lightly so I think
that the director had again I think that
Kaczynski when you look at that he has
an absolute uh very much of a reverence
for the predecessor for Top Gun and um
that may not have been the case for for
everybody who took that project on
okay Blade Runner no old versus new no
Blade Runner original Oh Blade Runner
yeah no Blade Runner 82
right 82 yeah I think so no Blade Runner
is it's not even a comparison people say
Blade Runner 2049 or play oh my God no
Blade Runner and and you gotta I mean
going back that that film has has stood
the test of time I mean when you watched
Blade Runner today and it's mini uh
forms right there's so many different
versions of that film from the narration
to the no narration to to so many but
whatever version you're watching uh what
Scott did with that film was so far
ahead of its time and the fact that it
still looks like something that we could
see on the screen today and not be like
well this looks really dated right the
effects evangelis score
um obviously Harrison Ford
um and you you look at that film and
it's a film that really uh expands your
mind especially as a young kid watching
that film it it that's a that's
absolutely one of the seminal films for
me when I talk about films that really
created my cinematic Soul it's it's
Blade Runner and then when I sat and
watched Blade Runner 20 49 as much as I
appreciate to me and I think that he is
one of our best directors I think that
he in that film almost every scene in
2049 runs too long it goes past its
natural expiration date right so you
have this natural point where the it
feels like the the scenes that's it
let's go to the next scene and we are
still there for a minute or two
afterwards like that's the flaw of 2049
is there's a there's a lot to like in
that film but usually my role ruled is
this whenever I look at a film it's
almost always this right less is more
almost always and I think 2049 at less
is better than 2049 at more which is
what we got which is interesting because
when you watch dude when I sat through
June I was expecting to see the exact
same issues I saw 2049
um because I I figured he he didn't
learn he's gonna you know he's gonna do
the same thing he did with with Blade
Runner 2049 and that's not the case Dune
uh really the pacing of Dune is is
something that I was surprised at I was
expecting that film again to each scene
go well past where the natural edit
point should be and it lingers on that
film doesn't somehow it managed to and
that's why Dune was my favorite film of
last year I mean it wasn't even a
contest uh dude the filmmaking to the
story I don't care you know the funny
people say oh it's a part one we can't
we can't give it best picture because
it's part one why what are the rules who
says that right who says that we have to
do Return of the King and wait for that
I mean if you you talk about that you're
Lord of the Rings Two is very clearly
the best of those three films I mean I
think there's no contest to that but yet
it didn't win but we have Return of the
King winning so you know who's to know
of Dune 2 is going to be better than
Dune one but this whole mindset if we
can't give it best picture we can't say
it was the best film of the year because
it's only the first part and it wasn't a
full film why well I don't am I missing
a rule
um so I think that mindset of that's
another thing that I think we have a
major problem with is is with awards for
sure is we can't do this because this
film doesn't fit into the parameters of
what an awards film is right it's it
it's not a horror film we can't have a
horror film be a best picture like
really why can't we why can't we have
hereditary as a best picture I mean talk
about a film that knocks you on your ass
and granted makes you feel like hell but
that's the point you know when I talk to
Ari Astor it was at the a24 party
um at Christmas and I saw ariaster and I
said I'm gonna you know when I first
came out of redditor I did not like your
film and then I thought I said no
actually I love it because you made me
feel like hell like I just been through
uh true hell and and that's the that's
the power of hereditary and that is
absolutely certainly one of the best
horror films of all time in my
estimation
um but why can't that be a best picture
why can't I mean just because it makes
you feel like absolute crap doesn't mean
it can't be a best picture but I mean we
all know that that's not the world we
live in we live in this world of it has
to be this up kind of thing I mean again
go back to CODA uh a true upper of a
film right absolutely
um and but but I don't I think we have
this problem where we have to say this
film is this we have to it can only work
in this Arena X is a great example same
thing from this year listen if you ask
me the two best films I've seen this
year it is X and top gun Maverick for
very different reasons but both because
they're extremely well directed
so really for me it starts a direction
the number one thing for a film is
direction there's not even a question
you can give an average screenplay to a
stud of a director a star absolute you
know top shelf director is going to take
an average screenplay and make a decent
film conversely an average director
given a great screenplay you might be in
trouble right because the choices are
different not everybody's going to make
the same film I mean you could watch so
many different versions of Any Given
film based on who the director is I
think it's a very singular individual
skill and the vision the artistic vision
of a director is the number one thing
for a film and so if the direction is
strong the likelihood of me liking it is
going to be very high
do you know usually within a min imum
within an opening
no you no no you you have a feel you can
know it's going to go down but I don't
know if you know if you can go up so if
it's really like the beginning and just
like some some of the choices are really
like wow that's that's something then
you start to go okay we're in trouble
but I think that
um unless I mean even top gun Maverick I
mean at the beginning I absolutely love
I think it's a perfect choice for that
film but I didn't at that point say okay
that means that the whole rest of the
film's gonna be good I think that's the
danger too you have to constantly when
you're watching a film you have to
constantly be on this balance board of
trying to say is what I'm watching
working or not and that can change
throughout the film you could start low
and end up High I mean I go back to a
film Looper
um Ryan Johnson's film I mean that is a
film that I was down on down on I was up
then I was down and then the choice at
the end was put me back up so his choice
of what what the characters do makes
Looper a film that I recommend but I was
up and down on that like a roller
coaster so I think think that's the keys
you're constantly evaluating it it's
almost like you literally have things
strapped right to your in your you can
almost judge those levels of where you
are on what you're watching you have to
be that way throughout the whole thing
because it could change you could love a
film all the way up until the end or
dislike it until like I said Looper up
um so you know you hopefully are going
to start pretty high and stay and ride
up right
um it's rare that you see something
starts really low and then you end up
really high so right so so I guess if
you see something that's not good yeah
that might be but if it's rare I mean
most films don't come out of the gate
and like oh my God this is terrible even
Firestarter I just I just fire starter
the weird thing about Firestarter the
Remake is that the first
25 minutes are decent you watch this
filming like I like some of these
choices I like the the title sequence is
really strong but that's a film that
starts here and goes down across the
board so those are those are rare too
what's the most you've rewatched a film
in the theater same film hmm
God do I want to answer this
it's probably a tie it's a Paddington
base oh God Paddington too well yeah
that unbelievable no I did not say that
multiple science I I think the the film
I've seen the most in theaters was Lost
Boys
because of that initial experience as
this 80s kid going in and getting blown
away by oh talk about one of the best
soundtracks of all time I mean lost boys
that I had the CD for not the cassette I
had the CV for Lost Boys And between
listening to that CD back forth back
forth and then going to see the film so
many times that summer right uh and the
other one would be cocktail
same time period I was a kid we were
bored you know it's summertime you're
like let's go to the movies and let's go
see something and you know let's go see
cocktail again I took multiple dates to
see cocktail it was the ultimate date
film sure and this was in Columbus Ohio
okay Columbus Ohio uh those are probably
the two and they each won probably six
times uh even though I I don't like to
mean I have seen fire starter now five
times the most recent one because it's
90 minutes long and there was nothing
else to see and I was bored and I'm five
minutes from this from the theater
that's why I went to see it five times
but I think you know what really the the
brevity of a film
adds to its rewatch ability because if
if you're talking about a three-hour
film
then you're you have to commit three
hours to that right that's a that's a
major time commitment conversely if a
movie's 85 90 95 minutes you it's today
you can watch it twice in the time it
takes to watch the other movie once and
you know one of my again a film that oh
I absolutely adore and from a filmmaker
that I think is going to really bring
stuff that we we it's going to be one of
our major major filmmakers in years to
come is uh is Rose glass I mean you you
look at Saint Maude Saint Maude is talk
about a film that you get blown away by
the direction and the choices and the
talents behind the the screen uh that
that is that is a film that uh is is
again rewatchable for that length as
well it's an 85 90 minute movie I think
that more filmmakers need to remember
that less is more less is more is such
an important thing
um if you can say something tighter do
it if you can make a movie tighter
almost all the time do it look at the
Irishman three and a half hours right
and now Netflix's has this whole thing
about you know it was a vanity project I
think someone actually added that quote
to what Netflix said but but when you
watch
Irishman or you watch a lot of things
that come out of Netflix you are looking
at a film that doesn't have the studio
constraints that are needed put upon it
and when I say that you go back to the
80s 90s 2000s Studios had more control
over their films they said this is the
studio head would say Hey listen your
film is going to come in at 140. you're
going to come in at 90. 150 Max now
we're bleeding into 220. 230 245 and
unless it's necessary vital to your film
less is more almost always so many films
that I see you say man there's a better
version here if you would have taken
things out not added you had the
opportunity to make this really well
certainly a better film and you left
more in this to lessen its overall
quality and I think that that gets back
to the director
you have to have somebody who you trust
to watch your projects and say listen I
like what I see but I think you need to
do this this and this and I think
there's not enough of that in Hollywood
and I know some creatives will think oh
man that is sacrilegious what you're
saying but if it makes your project
better then you should be listening to
those people who hopefully have a very
good track record it's saying this is
what I think we'll do we can do to
improve your film okay so taking the
less is more analogy let's look at the
social network and let's look at the
dialogue so the dialogue was just right
you think
Sorkin screenplay is uh again social
network is there's it's a Flawless film
it's uh which is those don't come along
often okay I don't care what film even
parasite I've got which I of recent
films which I think is again a
masterpiece I think there's a there's a
couple things that I would change drive
is a film that I oh God
uh I've seen drug I probably have seen
Drive 40 times that's a film that uh
really it speaks to me as a la person
for sure 40. oh yeah oh yeah I've
watched that I just watching a loop it's
a background it's one of those films you
put on in the background right and you
just have and it just makes you feel
even though Drive trust me depressing
film but the feels the score Martinez
the score and drive is just something I
can listen to It's on my it's on my iPod
on my on my phone I listen to that thing
all the time
um it just takes me to a space that is
that film and I'll never forget that's
another cinematic first that I'll never
forget the first watch you know Drive in
a press screen you know oh my God this
is reference wow uh and again it speaks
the love of Los Angeles and I think he
Nails it the feels of that film
um but but when you look at at these at
Social Network and you're talking about
a film that that uh again is perfect I
think this from the screenplay to the uh
again score screenplay Direction uh
acting every single element of that film
is perfect so there's not one thing of a
change about so that's I name a film I
can tell you one thing we could change
about for dry very easy for Drive I
think the number one thing I would
change with that film is in the elevator
head stomping scene where he is he's in
there with uh goslings in there with
Mulligan they're in the elevator you got
the bad guy there and he's going to do
something terrible to him he starts
stomping the guy's head in and and we
get it he's absolutely obliterating this
guy as he's down on the ground and you
don't see it right you don't see it so
refin at the very end the last shot boom
you actually see his foot go through the
heads right like smashing a pumpkin I
think if you do not show that and you
leave it up here right it's stronger so
restraint
is often stronger than showing it look
at jaws go back to Jaws right we didn't
see it was all in your head if the
terror is in your head if the horror is
there then it's stronger than actually
seeing it um I'm not saying that's
universally true but I think in cases
like drive and the elevator scene no
question that if Revan would have held
off on that instead pull back and had
left it up here it's a better film so
these are little things but they matter
I mean ultimately I would love to be
like a test screener of one show me your
movie and trust me I have no problem
doing this
reference would be here I'd say listen
man film is
you gotta be it's just such a film but
but the hellamator scene we got to get
rid of it we got to get rid of the head
stomping and and that's what we need we
need more of somebody who has the
ability to judge and probably okay
listen someone could say I'm wrong about
that that's fine but I think after
watching enough films and really getting
dialing in the skill of evaluation of a
film you become very aware of what works
and what doesn't work and I think that
is a very important skill to have on a
studio level because therefore you could
go in and say for any film and say I I I
know what I'm saying here I I think we
can make this film better by doing this
this and this and I think we need more
of that
Beyond Great Direction What Makes a film
amazing
um I think putting you in a world
creating a world that you escape into
that you are fully immersed in that is
um it's an experience that again takes
you out of your everyday and puts you
only into this it could be anything it
could be modern day it could be past
could be sci-fi it could be horror it
doesn't matter what the genre is you're
creating this full fully Alive world
that these characters live in and if
you're able to do that I think that
creating that setting that that is so
it's crucial to a film it sounds obvious
right but not every film is able to do
that but the best films are the ones
that literally place you in that
location with those characters and that
is again uh essential I mean it is
absolutely one of the key things that is
needed to be done by any director
filmmaker is to make you be part of that
world and it sounds easy but it's not
and not every film is able to do that
so with Blade Runner 82 that world was
was just like something fully realized
right yeah and again think of the time
right so you go back and that's uh 10 20
40 years now is that right uh 40 years
ago ish uh you're talking about uh you
know ahead of its time so many ways but
the production design on that film
um just the sets that were created I
think it's very important to have as
much real actual tangible things in your
film versus everything being CGI right
we get blinded by CGI films these days
just so much of it like Doctor Strange
to Multiverse of Madness you're looking
at a film that has so much CGI from that
opening scene it's just like I am
watching characters in front of a green
screen you literally can see the green
screen now in your head you just like
they're in front of a green screen I
think there's so much power in actually
putting those characters in an
environment a true real environment and
that's one of the reasons Dune succeeds
so well is because the production is
design of that film is authentically
it's real it is tangible it is not CGI
there's CGI in the film we know that but
more often than not practical sets are
where these actors are existing and that
is part of the World building that's
part of the production design of any
film I mean one of the best films I saw
from last year nightmare alley nightmare
alley del Toro's nightmare alley is such
an underrated film and and one of the
reasons is that production design you
know creating not just the carnival
world but also the Noir world of of New
York in the 30s uh or Chicago where the
city was um you know creating that world
the World building is just is is
everything to a film and uh it's it's
skill again that not every filmmaker has
so I think that's if you ask me
direction very clearly but it all still
comes back to Direction doesn't it I
mean when you talk about World building
it's the director's job to build the
world so that's why I say that the
director is everything I mean sure yeah
the script's important but the directors
skill in his artistic vision is by far
to me the number one skill that you need
to have as a filmmaker
what do you love about Marvel movies
I love the fact that everybody loves
them
I I there's something that is absolutely
to be cherished I think when we have
something that people like it it's we
need more of that and I think Marvel
movies
and dceu movies are really those things
that um get people excited I mean I I
don't get as excited for Marvel movies
as a lot of people do but but I
understand their value and I think that
there's a tremendous value I mean when
Scorsese says the things he says and I
know people say hey it's not Cinema and
this and that there's so many things
that are Cinema there's two there's we
can't Define Cinema as one thing right
it's only this it's only a small Art
House film
um no it's it's not it can it can be a
Marvel film as long as it again I still
I still want to see a very singular
directorial artistic Vision on the film
and I think that's where the Marvel
films sometimes lose their value is when
I watch when you have Chloe Zhao coming
in and doing eternals and when you watch
eternals and having obviously
recently seen Nomad land and then the
writer I mean the writer one of my
favorite films of the past decade when
you look at what's her talent and what
she does and then when you watch
eternals you don't see this same you can
see that someone came in and said listen
we love what you're doing but we're
gonna we need to put this in the Marvel
world so we can't let you go full Chloe
We Can't Let You Go full uh you know
whoever even rainy recently I think when
you watch Multiverse Madness you see
some parts that are Sam Ramey but then
you see other parts that aren't you see
other parts that almost feel like it's
from someone else and I think that's the
challenge and those are the things that
for me are the the hardest thing for a
Marvel movie is I wish that Marvel would
allow their directors to really impart
their Vision their individual singular
Vision on a film and an eternal is the
perfect example of that it just you
don't see Chloe like you do in Nomad
land the writer you don't see that
organic filmmaker
um you just you see it so sparingly in
the film that you wonder where she
disappears to right in the process of
the filmmaking and I think that's the
challenge as filmmaker when you step
into certainly an MCU film I think
Warner Brothers does a much better job
of allowing their directors a cart
launch in what they're going to do you
look at Joker and what Todd Phillips did
with that film would Marvel ever allow
that no there's no chance Marvel would
never Kevin feige would never let them
make a film like Joker if Joker were in
the Marvel Universe and Todd Phillips
said hey I want to make this super dark
king of comedy meets Taxi Driver version
of Joker Kevin feigen say no no way in
hell Warner Brothers said yes
I think Marvel would be better served if
it allowed its directors to do what Todd
Phillips did with Joker to go all out
and let that director really go after it
um and I think that's the challenge I
think as a filmmaker when you go work
for for Marvel you know that you're
going to be lost uh you at least you
better be aware of it now from watching
eternals go back multiple Doctor Strange
soup when you're a filmmaker and you go
in and you you look at at what Marvel
does with their films you don't see the
director as often and I think that that
is I think going forward if I was a
director
who really wanted to have my vision of a
film up on the screen I don't think I
would work for Marvel because I think
they're going to
dampen your impact
immeasurably
so you see the executive's note when you
watch no question a Marvel oh yeah when
you you see uh listen Marvel's a is a
listen they're the five billion pound
gorilla when it comes to to cinema these
days and Kevin feige obviously has a
very specific plan that is working for
them largely but as we get here into
phase four you're seeing some films like
eternals even strange let's hope that
Thor love and thunder is is stronger I
think that it's interesting as I say all
that I feel like taika waititi is given
more artistic Freedom with his visions
of those Thor films than a lot of the
filmmakers but he's earned that too you
gotta remember obviously this is now
going to be his third or is the second
third or third he's gonna he's he's been
in the system so I think he's earned
more trust but um but I think that that
when you look at these Marvel films I
think you absolutely see the studio
notes and versus the True full wattage
director
artistic Vision that you see in a lot of
these directors other films
is there a comic book character that was
either made better or made worse in the
film version so either way I did the the
comic book version was was one thing and
then the film became it comes down to
two performances for me the two
performances
um it's really about the actor and the
role there's there's a lot that have
been nailed I think that's true but I
think there's two without question
Robert Downey Jr is Ironman and Hugh
Jackman is Wolverine those are two
performances as those comic book
characters that frankly can never be
recast I don't think there's a way that
you could ever have someone else play
either Iron Man or Wolverine and get
away with it because they have cemented
their legacy as just iconic what they've
done with those characters I would never
want to try to step into those shoes
because it's it's virtually impossible
and I think those two in particular are
the absolute best of the best
um that said you know you go back and
look at you look at Joker I mean you
look at all the different ver Heath
leather
um Heath Ledger Joker you go obviously
Joaquin Phoenix Joker you're looking at
two great Jokers uh so there's you can I
think it depends on the character
um but at this point again with with
let's say both Wolverine and Iron Man
we've seen so much of Robert Downey Jr a
decade plus going back to you know truly
Marvel's first film in Iron Man
um that it's just a legacy that will
never go no one will ever touch that I
mean he is I think look at look at this
way Robert Downey Jr's performance is
Iron Man
elevated Iron Man from a mid Marvel
character right assignment to truly the
Mount Rushmore of Marvel characters I
mean you or Comic Book Heroes in general
comic book characters you're talking
about Superman Batman Spider-Man and
Iron Man those are my four Wonder Woman
five okay five on the thing right and
and obviously gal has done a tremendous
job even though Wonder Woman 84. oh what
a horrible film uh but she's great the
casting's right
um but but I think that that the way
that Robert Downey Jr elevated Iron Man
to this character that really again was
a mid Marvel character that's Robert
Downey Jr it's all him if you put
someone else in that film do we even
have the MCU like we we did I don't know
the answer to that if someone else plays
Iron Man
less iconically than Robert Downey Jr
did from the original all the way
through I don't think it's the same
Legacy I don't see how it's possible
he's so he was born to be Iron Man even
though I think he's graded everything he
does and he really needs to be working
in independent film if I was Robert
Downey Jr's agent I'd be like listen man
you need to be working with a24 you need
to be working with neon make some small
independent film he's a tremendous actor
I think people forget that about Robert
Downey Jr
um tremendously smart guy too if you
listen to interviews from him God
brilliant man
um but but I think people lose the fact
that that he is I think he's he might be
the singular reason why Marvel is the
way is what it is Robert Downey Jr so he
took sort of a mid-tier comic book
character and made it top shelf no
question I mean again Iron Man was no
one back in even let's go back to the
mid-2000s before Iron Man and you say
name uh comic book characters people
would not throughout Iron Man no way
they would throw out Hulk obviously
Spider-Man Batman the traditional
Superman no one would say Iron Man now
they would now now you would and I think
that's going to be the challenge going
forward too because now that he's gone
and I by the way do not bring that
character back okay you I as as tempting
as it is as much trouble as you get into
let's just assume that the MCU starts to
really go on a down slide do not ever
bring him back I don't care if it not in
the Multiverse nothing that's a perfect
ending to a to a character and and
you're going to tarnish the Legacy and I
think that will be a challenge because
ultimately if if you struggle you're
like well how can we get everyone back
well let's bring back Robert Downey Jr
um I'm sure he'd do it for the right
amount of money he made so much cash
playing that character but I think
artistically it's the wrong choice and
for legacy it's the wrong choice so I
hope it doesn't happen
why do you think comic book movies
dominate The Box Office
um
I think ultimately films are about
accessibility
certainly for audience and the larger
that your
pie chart is for the given film Marvel
obviously dominates like almost the
entire pie of of available moviegoers
right so you're looking at a four quad
film which means young old male female
everybody's in right families especially
so that's the reason Marvel was so
successful is obviously it's four quad
obviously you're talking about a film
that appeals to families superheroes
escapism it's got all these things going
for it that it's very easy to understand
why it's successful that said after
watching Multiverse Madness and going
back to eternals you're you're looking
at Marvel being in a spot where they
really need Thor love and thunder to be
not good they needed to be borderline
great or better because you're at a spot
where I think people are starting to go
I mean you've seen the the chatter on
social media people are saying I'm kind
of overcoming with movies I'm not as
excited now as I was and I think that's
the challenge is how do we recreate how
do we get that going again and
um for me again the answer is very
simple is allow these directors
to make the film they want to make
without
the overriding studio notes slash MCU
Kevin feige saying this is what we're
doing trust in your filmmaker to deliver
something that will re-energize the fan
base and when you look at Joker and Todd
Phillips granted it's completely apart
from the dceu but either way it's still
connected and look what that film did a
billion worldwide a film that people
were like what are we doing with an
R-rated CBM and it turns out to be
obviously an Oscars player Oscar's
winner and and a film that really
re-energized I think DC even if it's
disconnected but why because they allow
the director to make the film that he
wanted to make and most Studios wouldn't
do that Warner Brothers would get so
much crap for you know what happened
with Zack Snyder and I understand things
happen nothing's perfect in the studio
world but you have to give Warner
Brothers the credit they are due for
Taking Chances and we need more Studios
to take chances we lost Fox as you guys
know you know 20th century is now part
of Disney Fox was kind of doing their
own thing Deadpool and now that that's
gone you're you lost an entire Studio
that used to take chances like Fox did a
great job of doing that
um and now that's under the Disney
umbrella we'll see what happens I know
they're gonna make a Deadpool three will
it be in the same irreverent super R
hard R uh CBM that we've expected I
think the answer is yes because you
can't do that any other way but Studios
Taking Chances we we need more of that
and Warner Brothers does that
four quad you said it's young old so
four quad so yeah four quad film is is a
film that appeals basically to everybody
right so when you talk about a four quad
film you're talking about something that
when you look at the movie going pie
available audience of this pie chart
you're talking about pretty much the
entire pie chart filled in with one
giant slice of the movie going public
that will go see your film and you're
talking about young old uh male female
it's everybody right so so that's those
are Marvel films that's Jurassic world
Dominion that's
um you know it's not every film
certainly but the films those are the
films that are going to do the best at
the box office Maverick top go Maverick
is a four quad film even though it
probably is a little bit lesser on the
younger but you know the screening I
went to to show you how four quad this
is I sit down last Thursday when the
film opens here I am at Top Gun Maverick
I sit down on my seat four o'clock
screening on a Thursday on my right is a
woman that's probably in her mid 80s and
on my left a family with two young kids
under the age of five so you've got five
to eighty five right and someone in the
middle right there and it's just like
this is this is the whole pie this is
the four quad and you see it in action
and uh not every film is going to be
that way but but Marvel is and uh and
most Summer Films are going to be four
o'clock because they know the kids are
out of school Pixar yeah Pixar certainly
light year uh the Pixar would be a four
quad film
um you know any of those usually
traditionally you're going to see those
at Christmas you're gonna see them at
over the summer when you know you have
those kids available to you all day for
the matinees and all that stuff but but
yeah those are the films are gonna do
the best
I mean a24 first of all one thing you're
always going to get with a24 is a great
Direction you're going to get a great
directorial effort out of it I don't
think I can name one a24 film that does
not have very distinct strong Direction
now the problem for a lot of the movie
going public is that a24 films tend to
be for a much smaller slice of the
Cinematic pie so if you try to go see an
a24 film and you're expecting something
that is accessible or even remotely
mainstream accessible it's probably not
going to happen that often and I think
that's the the challenge that the
average moviegoer has sitting through an
a24 film that said they're invaluable I
mean good Lord look at all the films
that a24 has given us over the years
you're talking about really the Indie
distributor of note right of of all
maybe all time I mean you got Sony
Pictures classic in there you've got IFC
you've got neon now coming up obviously
but but a24 what they've done since you
know 29 and it to now they've created a
brand that's it's basically it's a cult
I mean people love a24 and there's a
reason because you're going to get a
very artistic film every single time
did you see the Revenant yes how did you
like it I don't think it's in urichu's
one of his best films I I think that
when you look at at the Revenant for me
and you look at
you look at Leo DiCaprio one of her
truly most talented actors that we have
today I think that he in every
performance is going to be exceptional
or better and when you look at that
being his Oscar when you're like that's
a shame because it's the Wolf of Wall
Street I mean if you ask me what's the
best Leo performance it's Wolf of Wall
Street it's not Revenant
um and that's the the thing sometimes
when when uh when we have those
discussions about what was the best
performance and it turns out that I
don't even think the Revenant was his
best I'm not saying it's a bad one but
it's like that's the one that we're
going to pick for the Oscar
um Blood Diamond sorry yeah I mean
listen you could name so many right uh
but I mean Wolf of Wall Street again
there's pretty much a perfect film for
me a three-hour film that is literally
one of the funniest films what a comedy
uh and yet so poignant about all its
points about the excesses of the rich
but but when you look at the Revenant I
just remember seeing that film one of
the first screenings of it and uh the
weird thing is when you go to see a film
like the red
and you come out and everyone is raving
oh this is the best film I've ever seen
and you go
did we watch the same film because that
happens and you you go are they right or
am I right you start to doubt yourself I
go back to the five Bloods the five
Bloods was a film that
I watched on a screener that was right
in the middle of the pandemic very early
on and Netflix had these huge hopes
Spike Lee black Clansman oh man what a
film I mean you want to talk about
recent Spike Lee films black klansman's
a million times better than the five
Bloods but I remember reading the
initial uh thoughts the social reactions
to defy Bloods the morning I the the
Embargo broke and I had my tweet ready
to go and I looked and I go
what the hell am I looking at like I
looked at my tweet and I looked at what
I'm reading I'm like Masterpiece this
movie's forgettable Master P what am I I
said okay I sat there for a moment with
my draft tweet of the review of the five
Bloods so and I said do I want to send
this am I going to get like what's going
to happen with this so I go
sent and then of course people ah look
at this he doesn't know what he's
talking about but here's the thing
ultimately what happened with that film
was it a huge officer Oscar success no
the five boys wasn't
you have to stay true to your initial
thoughts on a film and not be persuaded
to think otherwise and that's that's
hard because in there's people that are
going to come after you and say you're
wrong I'm not a huge fan of everything
everywhere all at once
and I have my reasons I think it's
successive I think it's repetitive I
think it's over long there are people
who think it's the best movie ever made
or up there okay and you have to stay
true to what you believe and as a film
critic evaluator anybody whatever your
opinion of a film is is your individual
subjective opinion that said if you look
over the track record of of somebody and
I think hopefully this is something I've
earned over the 10 plus years I've been
doing this is you have a track record
did this person which which side of the
coin were they on on this film were they
on the up down and and if you look over
the track record of your evaluations
your critiques of films if they are
largely where everyone kind of lines up
on it not that you're trying to do that
but if you are then then I think that's
that's key too because if you're always
on one side that's completely different
from everybody else that's different but
I think the other challenge is a lot of
people want to again like a Spike Lee
with defy Bloods you you'd say this is
Spike Lee so it's got to be good no why
why just because it's Spike Lee just
because it's director whoever name any
director Nolan Fincher anyone currently
working today
um any director uh you have to look at
that individual film The Past does not
indicate the future you can't go say
this is because every film they ever
made was good this one is and I think
the five blood is a great example of
that it's it's not a great Spike Lee
film and I stayed true to my thoughts
and I think over time I've been
Vindicated
oh you know oh you didn't like like the
following versus Inception yep I like
smaller films but but it's not something
that you want to raise your hand really
and and pronounce to the film Community
well you you do you're gonna get bullied
I mean even everything everywhere I uh I
sent a tweet after I saw it I heard it
was just so great everything everywhere
all once and then I I sit through and
I'm like man this is extremely
repetitive at the end
um they are bashing you over the head
with the same joke the same thoughts uh
almost an
it's just it's it's too much it is an
overload on the back end of that film
and I really it's funny that's a film
talk about a film I turned against it
was a film I felt great about everything
everywhere I was like I like this film
and then oh man it's the diminishing
returns and I started to go really down
on that but I sent a tweet out saying I
think this is
I want to start a a new group called
everything everywhere all at once is
overrated but I'm afraid no one will
join me because they're afraid to admit
it
Well turns out one of the Daniels jumped
on and said you know snarkly funnily oh
I agree with you we agree it's not a
good film like okay but what's
interesting is after that whole exchange
I didn't think anything so I'm not going
to change I'm not going to delete the
tweet this is what I believe what the
director says you know did I anger the
director I don't know but but you have
to be strong in your convictions
fearless and not worry about what other
people think of you you know I go back
to Cisco neighbor which I grew up with
watching that show at the movies uh you
know every Sunday on PBS I'd watch that
show and Gene Siskel is my film critic
hero of all time I mean I I think that
he his mind and how he evaluated films
watching him and Ebert go back but
especially Cisco I would listen to that
man talk and I'd say what a smart film
person I want to be like Gene Siskel one
day and one thing that he was was very
adamant about sticking to your original
thoughts on something never wavering and
they have a great exchange between the
two of them where he talks about the
death of a Critic so the death of a
Critic is wanting to be light wanting to
fit in wanting to be part of the group
being afraid of saying what you believe
to be your experience with this film and
like a lot of critics have an issue with
that because they don't want to stand
out they're going to be like whoa wow
you're the guy who didn't like
everything everywhere all at once yes I
am and I have my very specific reasons
why and I'm not going to be bullied off
of that platform
and that takes uh you've got to be
strong you've got to be fearless and go
I don't even care you just mute the
replies on Twitter I've done that plenty
of times a lot of film music art people
are on the fringes anyways yeah we're
kind of used to it yeah maybe that's how
we were in high school so okay great
that's how it is now 100 how I was yeah
um it's funny I had an exchange with my
friends last last night
um and we were at the hustle Premiere
and he said I think a lot of people on
Twitter they they think you're like the
bad guy the film film Twitter bad guy
because you're like the mean jock from
high school and I'm like that is so
funny to me as you say that because I
was a nerd I was a full-on geek okay I
yield back to Anthony Michael Hall and
16 Candles that's who I was okay kind of
in between not really cool and not
really totally a nerd but definitely not
with the cool jaw kids and but I think
that's the power of I think that's who I
am that's your power is that you're not
really one of anything you kind of can
belong to any group and I think we need
to do more of that is is to to be in the
same with films do not just ingest
Marvel product do not just ingest four
quad films go out and look for that tiny
film that will move you that gets you
excited about Cinema again I go back to
last year a very small film from Tim
Sutton funny face oh I mean that is a
film that I have watched that film I
have the Vimeo link to that and I have
absolutely exhausted the Vimeo views on
that I've watched it so much because the
mood of that film and the direction and
it's something I would have never
watched in the in the studio said hey
will you watch this movie we believe in
this film it was gravitas Ventures and I
go yeah it was it was like during
there's nothing else coming out I said
let's see this I'm so glad I hit play on
that because that was not theatrical I
had to watch a screener but that's what
you're looking for when I watch funny
face when I watch
Saint Maude when I go to we the animals
I'm these recent films they're tiny
films well St mods obviously a24 but we
the animals these are films when you
watch like wow this is what I love and
you know it when you see it it's just
the artistic quality of the film is so
high
and and those those are the things I
mean just like just vary your cinematic
diet do not just take in one kind of
film see as much as possible and uh and
stick to your guns ultimately stick to
your guns or whatever you think and
whatever you believe in Champion
okay so that being said you wanting to
stay true to what you believe in not
trying to please other people and say
okay I like this do you listen to film
critics and base what you see no you
don't okay never in fact I don't want to
I don't want to know
um a lot of times we're lucky enough to
have seen one of the first screenings so
there's not a lot of reaction out there
so we'll see you know Dominion I see
Jurassic world Dominion on Monday night
it comes out Thursday so I'll have I'll
see it where there's really not a lot of
reaction about it so my my reaction to
it will be all I have I don't have
anything else to base on I don't want to
in fact when there's a film that's
already debuted let's say it's Sundance
I didn't go tell your ride Venice any
Film Festival you name can I I'm gonna
not like Elvis is a great example comes
out here at the end of the month I don't
want to know about Elvis I've heard
Austin Butler's amazing you can tell
from the from the trailers that he
nailed this but I don't want to know
anything else because I don't want to
have my opinion altered by someone
else's opinion so I try to avoid it as
much as possible it's weird to me that I
hear there are people and I've seen this
I'm not going to name names there are
people who in Social reactions coming
out of a screening like say at Sundance
have actually looked at others you can
very clearly tell they cherry-picked
things and put it cobbled together and
put their own reaction together if you
aren't able to come up with your own
thoughts about a film that are
absolutely organic with you and not
originating from someone else then you
shouldn't be doing this you should only
care about your specific reaction to a
film I don't ever want to be influenced
by somebody else and that comes back to
being strong in what you believe in and
knowing
trusting your instincts
so same thing with music if we go back
to let's say the 80s or whatever and you
know whatever hit boy band of the you
know just just being strong in the fact
that I I'm sorry I can't
you know we've come up with a lot of
names I'm sure but you know guilty
pleasure sure but but something that's
on the fringes and being okay I'm a
fringe person oh and I'm I own it oh God
I'm flying my freak flag I don't care
100 and that's part that that's part of
the fun I mean like I said when I was a
kid I'd go I'd go to the record store
and I'd say they'd have the top 40
singles sitting there and I would look
at number one and I go nah that's I've
heard that a million times let's go down
to number 40. and let's take home number
40 because I haven't heard that and I
was always looking for the more obscure
thing and I think that's even for me
nowadays when I go well I really want to
watch things that haven't gotten the
attention they deserve ultimately
um they're rare I mean let's be honest
not every small film is worthy of
attention certainly not every large film
but the ones that are I think it's our
job to get the films that deserve
attention that are smaller and not
receiving any oxygen pump them up look
let's get those let's give them a Runway
um people have sent me tweets saying hey
Eric I think your service is really
valuable when you recommend something
that I didn't even know about and I
think that's the power of of what we do
is being able to bring eyes to something
that perhaps would not have them without
you saying that this is something you
need to put on your radar okay so you're
not promoting the soundtrack from Frozen
yeah okay there's no way no way but but
you know as I say that you can come out
of topic on Maverick and have the same
reaction which is completely populist
everyone you know as as American apple
pie filmmaking as it gets but
it still is a great film in what it's
doing and I think so you can't just say
because it's big means it's bad
um so you have to watch that too I think
a lot of people are like whoa if it's
not some small Indie then I don't it
doesn't have any value I'm like well
let's try to just have a film being a
film period period regardless of budget
regardless of Studio
whoever's directing who's ever whoever's
in it the film has value as a film
um that's it that's you have to look at
everything that way
we're hoping to play a little game here
we have five movie titles yep
we're curious first off which movie
title do you think is fake
well I know Val's real I know
centigrade's real
um
I would say leave a message after the
tone would be my guess because it's such
a goof title uh but then again
knowing really small indie film
um I'm probably gonna go with no I'm
gonna stick with that although my second
choice would be blood from Stone okay
okay okay and then what do you think the
genre is for each of these films okay
well I know obviously but I know Val
vows is is a documentary Centigrade I
have seen the IFC film it is about a man
stuck in his car with I believe his wife
or girlfriend and she uh he he dies and
then she it's just a real depressing
film but it is have seats in a great
he's stuck in a car and it's super cold
outside they're like in the middle of a
snowstorm
um blood from Stone would clearly be a
drama not familiar leave a message after
the tone has got to be a comedy if it's
real and then all roads to Perla I would
assume is a drama I am not these three I
got these two these three I'm uh failing
okay uh of these five titles which would
you want to see and and may I just
interject that Val is actually not a
documentary
so I thought foul was the Val Kilmer one
I did well the one we're thinking of is
Knob I'm giving you know what I'm
jumping in okay okay so which of these
five titles would you want to see
if I just had to go see a movie right
okay if I had to pick one of these five
to go okay I want to go see a movie I
would go with
Centigrade even though I know the film
and I wasn't huge on the film I would go
with Centigrade because I think that
um
I think that that's the most interesting
title to me it stirs my interest
okay and if we were going to pick let's
say since since you know Centigrade well
we'll leave that one if you're going to
pick one of these titles to be the title
of your next movie if you're coming in
Pitch an executive what would you tell
them the plot would be uh oh God
for for each all the other four okay so
blood from Stone okay so blood from
Stone would be about a depressed actor
who's been working in in Hollywood as an
extra for so many years by the way I
really do want to write the script so
this I wouldn't call it blood from Stone
when I'm trying to work my script in my
head into this struggling actor who's
been at it he's been an extra for you
know 20 plus years and and he just it's
by the way super depressing film because
ultimately he doesn't make it but that's
I think again what we talked about
earlier is that's the beauty of of a
good film is it doesn't have to wrap up
perfectly so he's trying to get blood
from a stone which is never gonna happen
for him in Hollywood so that's my that's
my pitch for blood from Stone
um leave a message after the tone would
be a goofball zany comedy
set in 1985
where the female lead heads out for the
night and she has on her answer machine
leave a message from the tone and it's a
very important call from somebody from
from what she's again let's make her an
actress again it's Hollywood she's
waiting for this call that she's been
waiting for to make or break her career
and it turns out that she accidentally
erases the tape and hilarity ensues as
as people as this as she tries to figure
out how do I get back into this after
erasing the message
um all roads to Perla
uh let's make this a dark horror film
and we'll have the a house
in the middle of nowhere and we'll call
it Perla and every Road in the town
leads to this house in Perla and and you
have multiple people coming from
different places to converge on the
house in Perla because all roads lead
there and then we get into a Knives Out
kind of situation
um Val
uh obviously I'd make a movie about Val
Kilmer no I if we can't do that uh I
would say Val would be a a female-led
movie that is about
an accurate I keep going back
let's make valid teacher Val is a
teacher and her everyday existence
dealing with her fourth grade students
and just this simple basic Cinema verite
of her life uh as a fourth grade teacher
almost like a documentary
okay and absolutely an awards film
right right it checks all the boxes okay
we'll go through the title tier great
job by the way I I love the the some of
it it seems like you were intuitively
picking up on it so number one blood
from Stone is a real film uh we
interviewed the filmmaker Jeff Ryan
great guy um it's a thriller vampire
movie the old era of vampires has been
forced into darkness yet they are drawn
to the dawning of a new era for
themselves with a longing to be free of
their Savage curse okay and this is Lost
Boys
uh sort of in Vegas
but they are yeah they're they're at a
casino okay okay yeah uh I don't know if
it's actually Vegas I think it's
somewhere else in Nevada uh number two
leave a message after the tone well
that's Karen's cheesy title so you were
right about that and it probably would
be an 80s type of a thing yes where she
goes out for the night and then the
thing is erased and how does she get it
back there right so you perfect I like
it I love it it's great uh number three
is a Val is a real movie but this is a
horror Thriller comedy and it's uh uh
co-written by Aaron fradkin and Victoria
fratz both of whom we've interviewed
great people
um it's a criminal On The Run breaks
into the home of a high class escort
only to realize nothing as as it seems
okay so kind of you had talked about an
actress you know
um okay
yeah number four all roads to Perla uh
that's a real film crime drama Thriller
and a great individual his name is Van
titavan to devong sorry I hope I said it
right sorry van I love you uh so a Texas
town awakes when a high school wrestler
gets entangled with a Drifter and her
Psychopathic lover lives then intertween
and spiral violently out of control once
he becomes her escort driver
yeah so
there we go
I don't know if you were expecting but
it's actually a fantastic film and um
beautifully shot oh you're having right
there okay yeah I highly recommend
cinematography we're there right right
right uh and then Center Grade you know
um it's Brendan Walsh great guy we've
interviewed him Thriller drama a married
couple finds themselves trapped in their
Frozen vehicle after a blizzard and
struggle to survive amid plunging
temperatures and unforeseenable
obstacles one for five great yes so you
knew Centigrade so
how many Oscars has Quentin Tarantino
won for best director oh that's a great
question I should absolutely have this
down I can say okay without answering
the question this has been out
Quentin Tarantino there's an example of
a director who is very
singular with his vision and knows
exactly what he wants to give you as an
audience he wants he's going to give you
the film that he has in his head is
going to be the product and that's the
challenge for filmmakers Is what's in
the head doesn't always come out into
the end product and I think Tarantino
maximizes his vision to actual
completion product uh maybe better than
any director I think Villanova's up
there uh but Tarantino's one for sure
and certainly as a director writer I
don't know if there's a better
combination
do you know how many Oscars he's won for
best director well I okay I don't have
the exact I'm gonna throw a number out
and say uh
well obviously we know that he was not
happy with bong winning instead of him
that's an interesting story by the way I
we can get into that or not but there's
a very interesting story with Quentin
Tarantino and Bong very interesting that
I I've never told well first of all
Tarantino would probably come after me
if I saw it but it's a good one
um but I okay for me I can say this he
should have won for Django Unchained
he did not win for Django Unchained he
should have one I will Django and chains
one of my favorite Tarantino movies
um I'm gonna say he has well the easy
the thing for me is I really should know
is I would say it's zero but I'm gonna
say one
your first your intuition is good zero
which is crazy right like I said you
think about Django just recently even
once up a time in Hollywood but you know
sometimes it's all about what's the
competition you know when you look at
parasite parasite was a phenomenon and
and once you get to that level where
parasite is just all-encompassing it's
it's gonna win the one thing I think
Tarantino would have and and this would
be this is the challenge I think for any
major filmmaker
um like a Tarantino he's having people
in your circle who are
capable
and strong enough and you listen to them
you value their opinion to say listen
man your movie needs to be shorter it
needs to be tighter and you have to Val
the director at that point has to Value
the opinion the person who's giving them
that obviously and I don't know if every
director has that ability to step back
and have other people assess their work
and allow them to make constructive
comments that might better the film and
I think hateful eight is an absolute
film that's too long
um so many films I see are too long I
mean it's it's it's not and it's not
really about length you know you could
watch a Immaculate three-hour film I
mean look at the Wolf of Wall Street to
me uh even Avengers end game these are
films that at three hours work okay but
there are also also plenty of films that
do not they they run too long again go
back to everything everywhere all at
once 225 if that movie comes in at 150
and you don't have as much repetition at
the end it's a great film as it is it it
loses its value as it extends past uh
its natural point where it really should
have ended and it's really about
tightening the screws and I think
filmmakers have to have that person in
their life that is that they value and
that they will listen to and they will
make the changes necessary if they if
they believe them to to be accurate and
you've got to find those people you
trust in your life I mean I think in
anything you do right but here's the
thing who who's gonna who's gonna tell
Tarantino right you're scared most
people are like I'm not gonna go tell
quickly it might go off on me
I don't I wouldn't have that you have to
have someone who's weary again it goes
back to that being knowing you in your
assessment of the product is accurate at
least as much as you believe it to be
and again having the instincts to know
and then having the fearlessness to say
I said I would love to do that Hey
listen let me watch your film and and
you could say I'm crazy and what I'm
telling you is absolutely wrong but at
least let me watch it and I will say hey
I think that we can do this this and
this and we can make a stronger product
sometimes maybe there's not nothing to
change but that's not very often it's
it's very infrequent that I see a film
that I don't go okay I think you could
do this this and this and it would be a
stronger product I thought Boyhood was
great oh and some people said it was way
too long and meandered I loved boiling
more than slacker so yes no Boyhood I
know that's maybe not a popular opinion
but Boyhood is a film
um was that 2012 13
14. a boy is a film that I saw in Boston
and I'd heard so many great things about
it and and I sat through it I just had
the birth of of my son and my daughter
was both extremely young and I'm
watching this film and I'm going
while this film is just everything the
the sad passage of time is something
that really hits me and when you watch
Boyhood you really see that right you
see them the shot over how many years
was that was it was it 15 years 10 years
whatever the length of time they filmed
it I can't remember now it's been so
many years but that that we're gonna go
shoot every year a little bit as the kid
grows up as the daughter grows up and
the sad passage of time is something
that will always resonate with me and
Boyhood captures that in a way that is
uh it's what makes it the film it is I
mean it's it's really something when you
talk about uh filmmaking and what link
later did with that film it just it's uh
it's truly one of the best films because
of that because of what he did the
uniqueness of that project
who deserves an Oscar more Tarantino or
Nolan
turned to you
yeah I think Tarantino again when you
look at you look at all the films his
his
portfolio of films is really with few
exceptions
um everything you're going to get from
him is going to be top shelf now that
said I think Nolan is absolutely right
there as well I mean Interstellar for me
is when you talk about Nolan films like
it's Interstellar and again what is that
hit down on it drills down on the sad
passage of time right so he comes back
and his daughter now is he's he stayed
the same age that that just blew me away
but there are things that Nolan does
that I go listen
I don't know what you're thinking is
this is what we talked about someone
needs to get to Christopher Nolan and
say listen I know you want to mess with
audio I get it I know you want to play
with that it's artistic you want to do
this strange thing and experiment with
the audio you do not experiment with the
audio IE dialogue of a film that is in
UD dialogue to explain films such as
Interstellar such as tenant you better
have that dialogue tenant it without the
dialogue you're like people are like
what's going on here but he buries it
behind Ludwig's score
um and hanza score an Interstellar I
remember sitting there in interstellar
and even Batman
um The Dark Knight Rises
I remember sitting in that screening
early this was a press read so it was a
before it came out and I'm sitting there
in this giant IMAX theater in Boston
going
why am I not hearing the dialogue this
is weird because it's usually dialed in
here the some things something's often
here and that was I think one of his
first things that he started to mess
with the audio Dark Knight Rises and
then you go to Interstellar remember
that was a big story everyone was going
Nolan people don't come to us and
complain the theaters were like don't
come to us and say that the sound's not
right Nolan did that it's not our fault
you shouldn't be doing that I don't know
what his thought process is I mean I get
it he's experimenting but don't do that
because it's lessening your films and I
think that again that gets back to what
we say these filmmakers need to have
somebody who is going to come up to them
like I just said here
stop messing with the audio and your
dialogue especially in these films that
need it you need somebody who has that
you value that tells you this is a
mistake because it is it is
um he might think it's cool you might
think it's it's an interesting thing to
do but it is it's making the it's
lessening the film and that's what we
say it's like the choices you make
ultimately either make the film better
or worse and Nolan's experimentation of
audio makes his films worse
I'm going to name seven directors I'm
hoping you can tell me which one has won
an Oscar for best director
number one Spike Lee number two Paul
Thomas Anderson
number three Ridley Scott for David
Fincher five Robert Altman six Alfred
Hitchcock seven Stanley Kubrick
this is another one of these trick
questions I know where you're these are
these are this is a gigantic list of
incredible directors that go back
through the the history of um you talk
about the vaunted uh directors of all
time and we're gonna end up with like
one Oscar winner right I can't fool you
yeah but here that's this is what this
crazy about this is that is that is is
is that's the maddening part of oscars
and awards is that it doesn't always go
to the best person and the list we just
had of these directors preeminent
directors of all time and and the number
is what a grand total of is it even two
uh there's seven and I believe the
number is zero
I was trying to say possibly I right out
of all these directors we've got to have
two that but that's but that's that goes
wow what what's happening here but again
I think you have to go back and look at
the films that they had that were their
best film and this just use Venture
because it's recent
um and we go to social network and you
say
um he's he's in the right place and you
just go how did this not happen because
there's something else that caught fire
it happened so often in award season
where you have something all of a sudden
gets momentum and then it just goes
snowballs up Coda just happened that's
exactly what happened to CODA it was
really a movie that no one was talking
about as even an awards film really a
major player when Apple acquired that
out of Sundance Coda was sitting there
they put it out I believe in August of
last year and everyone was like yeah
it's fine it's fine you know we like the
film's good but then it kind of went
away and then Apple said we're gonna
really attack this film as an fyc film
as an Oscars film and let's push this
and it started getting momentum it
started winning you're in here but if
you go back
at code and you look speaking of
directors and you look at uh Sean hater
who directed that film I don't believe
she has a single nomination from any
critics group
anywhere which is really unheard of for
a film
um you know when you talk about a best
picture you're at least talking about a
director that's in the conversation
um and I think that that's a real rare
occurrence when you look at Coda but a
lot of times it's really about timing
these these directors had something that
caught a film that caught fire up
against them and it was that director's
moment but the fact that you have zero
is just it's I know that's it's baffling
because you you go back and you go how
is that possible
um but you'd have to go back and look at
every year and say what was it what was
the film that came through and like
King's speech and just was like oh it's
King's speech and you're like it's The
King's Speech really you're kidding me
no but as you go back you assess it and
you're like that was the wrong decision
I mean it was objectively which which
film stand stood the test of time King
speech or social network okay I mean any
even Tarantino I believe even recently
said social network is his best film of
the past decade and probably Beyond and
and again I'm not it's not my best film
of the past decade and beyond for me
because of Quentin Tarantino but I love
hearing when another director says the
same thing that's awesome you know and
I'm going to say an unpopular opinion I
love Molly's Game
Network yep maybe just a female
protagonist so I identified more but I
absolutely love that but don't forget
that Sorkin directing ah okay so so
that's Sorkin directing good point right
so but you know it's interesting here so
okay let's talk about that's I love how
you brought that up because when you
talk about director and screenwriter the
combination not every director is a good
writer and not every writer is a good
director okay when you look at Aaron
Sorkin you look at a writer who is one
of the best if not the best work in
Hollywood today right and you give him a
script such as social network and then
you couple that with David Fincher
direction and you get Social Network
then you flip it and you go to trial of
Chicago seven and you get Aaron Sorkin
writing and you get orange Aaron Sorkin
directing and you don't get anywhere
near not even in the same universe and
it speaks to I think that these are two
different skills Direction in writing
are not the same skills and I think
there are some director writers that
maybe should just be directing or maybe
just should be writing um and I think
Aaron Sorkin has yet for me prove that
he's at certainly an Adventure level but
few are but but still maybe you know
maybe you're just a writer maybe you're
just a director there's directors I've
seen that have written and you're just
like I I saw something recently where I
said I think that if you give if you
would have directed this and let someone
else write the script it would have been
better I mean this is Something's Gonna
Pop in my head but but again those are
two distinct skills and and I think we
have a bleeding sometimes and sometimes
you can't do it all maybe you can but
the chances are lower the more that you
try to do that's well right direct act
you can have someone who does all these
things well I mean Clooney has had some
good films directorially and he's been
in uh but but I think it's it's hard
it's really hard to get all of those
skills because these are all different
things you're juggling three completely
different things Ben Affleck and Argo
100 oh he shows the Instinct right there
right Ben Affleck in Argo uh you know
argo's a fantastic film a crowd pleaser
all these things and and he he shows a
ton of talent then you go look at this
movie that he did like a few years after
that I'm forgetting it now it was like a
Warner Brothers film period piece with
him and um uh but it was not a great
film so it's again it gets back to you
can have one great film that doesn't
mean every film you ever make for the
rest of time is going to be great
um and and that's the importance of when
you go down to watch a film and sit down
is to forget all that you know about the
director and what you're about to see
and just evaluate what is there on the
screen not who's behind the camera
what is on the screen and I think there
are people in this business film critics
who get bogged down in who's the
director this this and this I'm like it
doesn't matter ultimately it doesn't
matter when you think about it it's it's
really about the final product
period
what do you think about gray man having
a limited one-week theatrical run no I
don't like it I mean I think Netflix is
theatrical uh plans are just in disarray
they don't have a theatrical component
to their films Netflix needs a
theatrical component because at the end
of the day we all know this it's just
it's a fact when a film is in theaters
you its visibility is higher it's got
more cachet it just that's how because
that's that's how I was as a kid I mean
we all went to movies there was no such
thing as day and date at home right like
Netflix or Disney Plus or any of these
things that Hulu any name of name is
streaming service it was all about
theatrical and anything that wasn't
theatrical was a TV movie so it wasn't
viewed with the same lens it was like
this is a lesser film because it's not
on the big screen and that's Netflix's
challenge is getting people to accept
them as a studio such as Warner Brothers
Disney 20th century obviously part of
Disney Sony Universal these Studios
Paramount that have the Legacy that
Netflix does not have but the way you
build Legacy is you have to have a
theatrical component so when I look at
the gray man a film that's I believe a
200 million dollar budget with the Russo
Brothers 200 million dollar film and you
don't have it in theaters Beyond one
week and by the way not even the major
change not AMC not Regal it is you know
Cinemark or even smaller and and you
have this 200 million dollar film you
have to have at least a 30 to 45 day
window theatrical window right these be
90. so let's give it 30 that's a month a
month before it's on Netflix it's at AMC
Regal the major chains figure out some
kind of sharing I don't know how the
profits work with with all that stuff
the ins and outs the numbers but I know
this they need to get that because it'll
add cache to their film so instantly
when you ask them about the gray man I
say eh it's lesser because it's not a
theatrical film it's not
um you know a universal release or a
Warner Brothers release it is it is
going to be on Netflix a week after and
again we can't even in La it's gonna be
very hard to find theatrically so
Netflix has to figure out how to get
their theatrical game going I can't
believe they don't have it done by now I
mean it is I'm hearing finally you're
hearing these stories in the trades that
they're thinking about I'm like thinking
about it how did you not do this like a
year or two ago I've been saying this
for forever it's such a vital part of
the visibility of a film is the
theatrical component okay do you think
some of their reasoning behind this is
like pressure by like hey this sort of
like this is only on sale for this
weekend folks so because of rising costs
and things like that
give people one week now there's
pressure we want to see this on the big
screen no I think I think that's that's
the op the flip of that so because it's
only one week now you're telling
audiences you only have to wait a week
to see it
look at Paramount and what they just did
with top gun Maverick they gave it 120
day theatrical window that is four
months that's longer than the the old
90. so what you do when you announce
that it's a four month theatrical
exclusive you are forcing people to go
to the movie theater to see your film
and
um and I think the listen I think we're
in a different place now than we were in
2020 certainly when code first hit I
think if you look around look at the
audiences I'm seeing at films now it's
back to the 2019 pre-pran pre-pandemic
levels
so why not uh give audiences the
opportunity to go see it at a theater
where it's going to be that communal
experience where it's going to be
something that they're going to remember
far more than watching it at home I mean
every single time theatrical beats home
viewing
99.99 of the time so unless someone's on
their cell phone okay or talking or
kicking your chair those are those are
separate issues but the actual
experience of watching on a big screen
with a crowd in your recliner if you
paid the up charge these are all better
and I think that another thing that's
that's really great about films and I
think about going back to watching Top
Gun Maverick just you know last week
seeing young kids and older folk right
next to me this wide swath of all ages
going to this film this might have been
their first film back into a theater
right because they've been you know had
coveted they've done the whole thing and
maybe they were a little leery about
going back then they go to see top
Maverick
and they take the precautions they need
to take but they say to themselves hey
you know that wasn't so bad and now I
think I'm over my fear and now I'm gonna
get out and not just go see movies I'm
gonna go live life more than I have in
the past two years so movies are the
vehicle for so many other things I mean
just think about that breaking that
plane of being frightened of going
outside your house and all of a sudden
you go to see top gun Maverick and you
come out you go first of all I love the
movie second of all I'm alive a few days
later
hey let's go try this and this and this
and then you regain where we were before
which is so important right living life
fearlessly because if you if you're
living a life of fear
um obviously you're not living so I
think again uh just think about taking
something small like that and then
extrapolating and out and saying wow
look at what it just did for for
somebody I think about that too
so shortening the window of opportunity
for theatrical actually has the opposite
effect 100 yeah yeah shortening the
theatrical window absolutely makes your
film it puts it in Peril uh box office
wise because people are now going to say
I can wait 17 days certainly I can wait
a week but even you know look at HBO Max
was doing that all throughout the
pandemic pandemic day and date right it
was on HBO Max and it was in theaters
and look what happened every one of them
suffered because if you give people the
opportunity to watch a movie at home
they're going to take it nine times out
of ten right eight times out to seven
most people are gonna go I'm gonna stay
home
um I'll say it's cheaper uh I don't have
to drive to the theater whatever it is
so I think if you give them the
opportunity to watch at home you're
going to lose a huge segment of your
movie going public right right there and
then also people will just say I'll just
wait it out if you tell them it's going
to be on in 17 days if I was running a
studio I don't think I'd even announce I
would just say hey it's in theaters
we'll let you know when it's going to be
on our streaming service because once
you announce it you instantly give
someone a deadline that they know I can
only I only have to wait you know five
weeks I can do that but if you make it
uh just TBA then then they people go I
want to see this movie because right now
the world Works certainly on Twitter
film Twitter and social media is people
want to talk about movies now what are
people talking about now you don't want
to be talking about a film you know
three weeks from now I was like oh my
God that's all we already did that we
already did that discussion I mean
people go to see movies like two days
after the open now so sorry I'm late to
have seen this film it opened two days
ago but that's the world we live in now
it's white hot at the moment so I think
that's what theatrical that's how it
thrives is by making people go see the
movie at the theater if they want to
discuss it and people want to discuss it
so they're going to go to the theater
how much money do you think the gray man
will make in theaters for this one week
theatrical not much in fact remember
this Netflix does not report its box
office we'll never know so they didn't
know that Roma had a small theatrical uh
Power the dog had it I mean a number of
their films had that one week window
like especially the wards films but they
never announced the box office they keep
that down uh Army of the Dead I believe
had that for a week I think the reports
got out didn't do that well but again
it's not going to do well because a week
is nothing for people to wait they'll be
like whatever and plus remember it's not
at every theater like if I want to see
the gray man I have to probably go find
it at a smaller theater here in La I
can't just go down to AMC because they
don't have a deal with AMC so it we'll
never know but I'll bet you it's not
very big because it's not going to be
available everywhere now if it was one
week at AMC Regal with the larger chains
I would say better but again the week is
not good you really want to make it a
month minimum because otherwise you
afford a cycle to sleep oh wait
let's talk about red notice uh how much
money would that have made
apparently it was one of Netflix's most
popular films streaming all time um I
mean you have three major stars in that
The Rock gal Ryan Reynolds you got these
three major Stars I mean if that's a
universal film
um I can remember when that came out it
was like it was still during the
pandemic so we had that would have been
shifted but let's just say red notice
comes out today and it's a universal
film okay that opens with at least 40
plus million
um maybe higher even though it's not a
great film
um but again average person seems to
enjoy it enough look at the lost city
lost city is a Paramount movie obviously
with Sandra Bullock and and Brad and and
Channing and it did very well for them I
think red notices very much of that and
I think it made over 100 million Lost
Cities so I think red notices easy over
a hundred uh domestic alone probably
throughout the world certainly more
because it is uh the rock will travel
Ryan Reynolds travels gal would travel
all those would go do well overseas but
it's hard to know because because it's
Netflix if it was Universal uh I still
think it would probably be about a 45 50
50 million dollar opening and then at
least 100 million box office so Netflix
leaves that out right so Netflix doesn't
have that all of a sudden
um do they gain more subscribers I don't
know I'm not privy information but I
just don't understand how you don't make
money while you can in theaters for at
least a month or two and pocket that 100
million or so or more and and now you
don't have that it's just it's just like
leaving money on the table I don't
understand the philosophy other than to
drive people to subscribe to Netflix but
I still feel like they're going to
subscribe anyhow they might want to
watch it for a second time at home so I
just think that who Netflix needs to
absolutely revamp their model certainly
for their big films not for every film
but for their big films you're spending
all this money on your budget 200
million for The Gray Man and you're not
going to put it in theaters why it
doesn't it just doesn't compute with me
um the business doesn't make sense to me
and again it cheapens your film because
it's not theatrical
what if Netflix puts the gray man
exclusively in theaters for one month
and it fails at the box office how much
would a massive failure cost Netflix I
know we don't know too much about their
box office numbers right
well first of all we'd have to know what
the numbers are right so we'd have to
know they'd have to report the actual
number and we'd know
um but I don't think given it's July
it's a four quad film right largely it's
probably three and a half I mean young
kids are probably not going to see the
gray man but let's call it pretty wide
you've got major stars in that film
obviously so you're looking at a very
large chunk of the movie going pie
um does it damage the film if it bombs
um I mean are people gonna unsubscribe
from Netflix no um so I don't think it
does anything I I don't think it affects
Netflix's long people aren't going to
unsubscribe and you made at least
something from the film so I'm trying to
ascertain what is the downside of of
putting a film theatrically it doesn't
other than
the sharing the revenue right because
the theater the chains get their money
in in the studio gets money but still
isn't any money better than no money
plus the subscribers again it just
doesn't work I can't get my wrap my mind
around it
are movie theater is upset that Netflix
has hurt their business
they probably they definitely were
during the pandemic I mean during the
pandemic everything was streaming right
look at Netflix the stock was through
the roof now it's tanking people were
stuck at home so of course they're
watching Netflix or Hulu or Amazon any
of these things
um but but I think theaters were at that
time I don't think anymore I feel like
that's gone I think Netflix the problem
Netflix always wanted this really uh
short window they're like we'll give it
to you for seven days or ten why not
just make it 30 okay figure out a way
45.
um there's got to be something I would
love to sit down with Scott stuber who I
saw last night the head of Netflix
um and ask him what's your reasoning I
would love to hear someone because I
guess they're finally talking about it
but I'd love to know what was your
reasoning for not doing it you didn't
want to put up with the hassle what's
the answer but but I think that no
there's no down if it doesn't do well I
don't think it doesn't anything you
still have money you made something from
the film plus you're gonna get people to
subscribe to watch it even if it's bad
people still watch bad movies
sometimes they watch them you know more
than the the good ones yeah I have
watched Fire Starter five times in
theaters first of all I have a list from
AMC which is the best thing ever okay
sorry if this is advertising but amca
list is literally 24 for 12 Movies a
month 12. three movies a week okay for
24. so net once I got that I'm like hey
I've got three movies this week let's go
see Firestarter again so and it's
because it's bad so I've sat through
Firestarter five times because it is bad
it's 90 minutes and I have a list but
there's nothing wrong with seeing
through a bad movie sometimes it's more
entertaining so you can laugh at it do
you think Netflix will ever buy movie
theaters they should have I I thought
they were gonna with ArcLight right I
thought that they were going to go down
there I know they have the Egyptian but
I thought that they were going to go buy
ArcLight Hollywood which would have made
so much sense it's sitting there it's
still empty I don't know what's going on
with orchlight Hollywood but it would be
perfect for Netflix they're down the
street they have two offices right one
on Sunset one on Vine and they have two
campuses right there we can walk over to
Arclight I don't know how that didn't
happen
um but it would be the perfect showcase
for their films put that in the cinema
Dome Center cinorama Dome put it in the
center Ramadan and then you have your
number one film in that giant screen and
and you don't even care about profits at
that point you own the theater so if you
if it's a giant you know that's a huge
room obviously and let's just say it's
not full who cares you're giving that
film the stature that it needs
um to again that theatrical component
that adds to the stature of your film so
by arkline Hollywood and then stick your
films there and and then have other
films maybe that's their issue too they
don't want to be you know I don't want
to have a universal film and a Paramount
film and a Disney film in with ours I
don't know what the point is I mean I
would not suggest they buy
The Arc Light input all Netflix films
that would not be the suggestion I would
just say buy it and then put in your
films where you want in the Strategic
rooms you want and then let the other
Studios out there so you can't just have
the because the world doesn't run only
on one Studio's film so we've seen that
you really want that diversity of of
different Studios and distributors maybe
that and expose them to liability
it could be that too I I I don't know
you know it's weird I don't know the
business of it I just it just doesn't
make sense I just think at the end of
the day the bottom line is this is the
theatrical ads to your film The cachet
of your film and without it with that
missing theatrical component it is it's
degrades and devalues your film I 100
believe that
do you think we'll be seeing some TV in
in theaters TV shows
I mean you look at some of the films Sex
in the City Entourage
um Downton Abbey I think the danger with
seeing TV shows and movies is that
you're limiting your audience right off
the bat so when you have a show such as
Downton Abbey I never watched the show I
haven't seen one or two of the movies
because I'm not I don't know anything
about Downton Abbey so I understand
people say you don't have to but it
still is like I don't watch the show so
you're limiting your audience right off
the bat so if you look at I mean Sex in
the City did well but Entourage didn't
it was plus it was passed when it really
should have been but I think when you
make a TV show into a film you're
instantly making your audience smaller
and I think as a film unless it's a very
very popular series I don't think I want
to do that as a studio I think I want to
have a film that I can get as many
eyeballs as possible into the theater
because that's where you make the most
money because ultimately it's a business
right I mean we as much as we love films
it's still a business and these films
have to make money where they're not
going to make the films and that's why
we should all want these films succeed
from from the biggest film to the
smallest film because the big films do
help Finance those smaller films and
maybe they'll take chances you look at
the northmen the northmen focus film
they spent in the budgets anywhere from
70 to 90 million I've heard all kinds of
things the danger of the northmen I
think the lesson of the northmen is this
and Robert Eggers certainly learned it
Focus learned it is that when you give a
filmmaker 70 to 90 million dollars to
make a film and you make a film that is
more accessible than the witch
definitely more accessible than
Lighthouse but when you give someone
that much money to make a film you have
to then as a filmmaker yes you want to
make the film you want to make but you
also have to understand that you've just
been given a big responsibility with
this cash it's a lot of money that you
need to make a film that is more
accessible to a bigger audience so that
you now can get another film made
because I think Robert Eggers even just
recently said I've learned a lesson well
you should have known that ahead of time
I was saying that you know the danger of
this is that now is focus ever going to
give 70 million to another young up and
coming director probably not they're
like we got burnt by the northmen we
lost money on the Northman I mean I
would never have given Robert Eggers 70
million to make the Northman there's no
chance I can't even believe that
happened
um and I value his filmmaking but I also
understand that the films that Robert
Eggers make is not a wide audience a
wide scoped movie it's a very again more
of a niche and Northman is wider but
it's not as wide as it should be and I
think that's that's the the lesson of
the Northman is that with great power
comes great responsibility and they gave
him an opportunity to succeed with this
massive budget and he delivered a film
that underperformed and it comes back to
the director and the choices that he
made in the film it's a fine film it's
not a bad film but it could have been
more accessible and I know that's
probably not what he wanted to do but
again he's not going to get that
opportunity again anytime soon
I think you've said we need more family
films for theatrical why is that
well family films um or I mean again
just go back to my childhood going to
films with my family going to see
Richard Donner's Superman I'll never
forget that with my friend and his
family it's just like that all it's
ingrained forever just right now I have
not thought about it until this moment
but going to films with your family I
took my kids when they were young to so
many films when we lived in Boston I was
I was doing TV there and we went to see
like no joke two movies a week and there
were so many family films huge uh hugely
popular time for animated films the
early 2010s you had so many of them like
literally one a month and I took them to
all of them but family films are really
the Bedrock because it drives people
into the theater as a group right four
or more maybe your families too whatever
the number is It's a larger group of
people going to see the movie and
they're going in and supporting Cinema
which again flows down with the success
you're gonna have Studios having more
money and take more chances on Films I
think that's why we want all these films
to succeed but family films are really
the Bedrock of that so go back to Marvel
Marvel is the Bedrock of cinema right
now ultimately whether you'd like it or
not we want these films to succeed
because it drives people in you may not
like them but you need to appreciate
what they the value of a MCU film and
dceu you need to appreciate that when
these films succeed it's good for the
entire Cinema ecosystem and I think that
is where some people get lost they want
to see these films fail I never want to
see a film fail ever because it's bad
like the Northman I no one wants to see
that film fail because I want to see
someone else be given 70 million dollars
to make an independent film uh you know
even though the Northman still an
independent film but a big film Rose
glass I mean God if I could give Rose
glass 50 million to make a film I would
trust her to make a badass film
um you know Saint Maude is just I mean
it's just one of those experiences you
just go wow this is Talent
um but but it really comes back to
really you want to see everything
succeed because it benefits everyone so
never root against a film ever do you
really think there are people rooting
against something yeah oh yeah I mean I
see it on I see it online all the time
if you say if you say you don't like a
MCU film The then the MCU people say oh
you're a dceu guy and then conversely
the other way I love DCU or you hate MCU
no I don't have a dog in the fight I
really am just again neutral watching
the film does it work does it not I
don't even care what the label is we got
to get away from all that you can't it
doesn't matter you just want to see a
good quality film and it doesn't matter
what brand of comic it comes from what
studio what distributor none of that
stuff matters it's the film ultimately
so you need to get less into these
tribalistic thoughts it doesn't make
sense to me uh I'm definitely not
tribalistic I think everyone needs to
become become less tribal it's become
your own thinker right don't don't
follow everybody else unless it's the
right thing to do but if it but think
about it make make your own critical
decisions and I think that's ultimately
what we the job we have as film critic
film evaluator is to be absolutely
unbiased and try to see the film as
neutrally as possible so that when you
say something's good and bad
um you you have that value that your
words stand for something
why do popular franchises fail
I think that it gets back to when
the filmmaking turns inorganic and I
think that that's hard to describe when
that happens and what that is but it's
it rings true or it doesn't and when a
popular film goes in a direction that
doesn't feel authentic to the characters
and who they are and their motivations
as we've seen over the years then that's
where the franchise can be derailed and
that is why Top Gun Maverick's a great
film is because it's very true to
everyone from the 86 version to now the
2022 version uh to the to the sequel is
that it is organic and it's grounded in
who these characters were so that's how
you do it right and then we've seen how
it's done wrong where you just watch and
you go wait that character would never
do that or what was that decision and it
it almost always just comes back to
something that feels inauthentic
inorganic and often ungrounded and and
that's uh I think know what happens a
lot of times a lot of filmmakers try to
do too much I think there's value in not
doing a lot
um you know I look at the Darden
brothers and talk about their style of
filmmaking is just so raw and so rough
no score just just here it is almost
documentary style that is there's value
in that I think that if every filmmaker
found some value in that bringing
everything down it's rarely about
bringing things up it's usually about
bringing down the level a little bit
right even in Hustle that I watched last
night there's a scene where Adam Sandler
has to talk to somebody who's trying to
save his career and you're watching Adam
Sandler and I'm going uh he's doing his
comedic thing where he's out of control
almost he's yelling and I'm like if he
would have grounded that just bring that
down here then it's better and I think
that's obviously up to the director to
do that because they they're in charge
of the actors but as a screenwriter your
job is to again just keep the motivation
of your characters as authentic as
possible and I think ultimately for me
it's always about bringing things just a
little bit down it's rarely about
ramping up it's bringing things just
down sometimes a lot but let's just say
even that much just that much is
significant right so if it's very often
I see that it's usually less it's always
less is more almost always 99.9 of the
time less is more in everything in film
which franchises in the worst shape
right now
I think Marvel's in trouble I mean
listen Doctor Strange too Multiverse of
Madness is not
a great film okay and again when I
watched that film I see times that I see
Sam Rainey and then there's other times
I don't it's almost like there's two
films right and it feels like it was
cobbled together and nothing in that
film ever Rises to a level you can watch
so many films and you have some that
really pop something in the movie is
just like oh my God and and then we've
had plenty of films that you really are
pinging that top right Doctor Strange
never even pings it's just a flat line
and and you go back to eternals and and
what Chloe was not allowed to do with
that film clearly I think Marvel really
needs for love and thunder to be
essentially a home run I think that
people are the brand is starting to feel
to feel devalued and I think that also
speaks back to the Disney Plus shows
there's too much product remember less
is more it's it's always just comes back
to that essential core less is more and
now we've got more is more and you've
got all these shows Miss Marvel and
She-Hulk and and uh what's in a Moon
Knight uh all these shows I don't watch
the the Marvel shows I just stayed with
the Cinematic Universe but when you
start asking your audience to watch
shows as homework in addition to
everything else you're starting to make
your audience right you're starting to
bring your audience down and I don't
know what the I understand they want to
have a bunch of successful shows but the
more you do the more work you require
like Doctor Strange if you didn't watch
One Division you're like what right you
it was required viewing to watch One
Division and I don't think that's the
best path so they're Marvel's in this
state where they're trying to figure out
how do we work our Disney Plus shows
into our Cinematic Universe organically
and I think it's a challenge for them
because not everybody's watching the
Disney Plus shows and therefore the
impact of your film is going to be
lessened because the people don't have
the experience that they need to really
value the film at the level that it
needs to be to be truly appreciated
because you don't have they haven't
watched it like watching a sequel to a
film you never watched the original
you're gonna have the same reaction to
top gun Maverick
as you did uh if you'd seen Top Gun
versus you'd never seen it you're just
not it's the two in combination that is
where that comes right that's where you
have that experience that is next level
because they work in Symphony with one
another and and that is I think Marvel's
problem right now is that they have
their Disney shows and they're trying to
combine them with their Cinematic
Universe and it's not really going that
well it's I'm sorry strange too is not a
good film
eternals is very mid and then you're
sitting here on Thor love and thunder
and let's just hope taika went batshit
with it because if he did then maybe we
can get back on track the fact that
Guardians are back in this film is is
obviously a win for them this is pretty
much we're getting back to that core
Avengers group right Thor and the
Guardians you're back to the Avengers
more so and I would also argue going
back to strange that doctor strange is a
supporting character he's not a lead
right not Cumberbatch car matches is a
badass okay
great actor but as a lead I feel like
Doctor Strange supporting very much as
we saw him in no way home he's not the
focal point and I feel like Thor's more
of a focal point a focal point so Thor
love and thunder should be better off
that way Hemsworth and Thor more of a
focal point as a main character for me
than doctor strange but there's a lot of
pressure on Thor love and Thunder
so having a film where the audience
needs to catch up on prior episodes or
or universes or whatever is is a recipe
for disaster you're asking listen
anytime you ask anybody to do more work
they're largely gonna probably not I'm
good I don't want to back to Downton
Abbey I haven't seen Abby one or Abby
Two And the reason because I never
watched the shows someone said well you
don't need to Abby 2 is a really nice
get you up to speed right off the bat
when you go into it I'm like I don't
care I don't watch the shows so you're
asked your limit you're restricting your
audience and again
um you have if that's what you want to
do that's that's your decision but again
if I'm making a film I still want to try
to make a film that is as accessible as
possible to the widest group of people
not every film is going to be that but
for a Marvel film it better be right
that is
accessible to everybody it better be
um so when you ask them to watch for
homework Wanda Vision or Moon Knight
whatever that is you're asking them to
to sit through Eight Episodes plus go to
the movie I I don't know I think that's
the challenge for Marvel right now is
again how do you do that so you are
limiting your audience when you ask them
to do homework outside of the film
are there any franchises right now that
can do no wrong
uh I I feel like Jurassic world's run
its course so I I don't know we're going
to find out here with Dominion
um
okay that's a good question what
franchise I mean we obviously have
Marvel we have DCU
um I I can't think of any franchises
that uh I'd have to have a list in front
of me because I can't off the top of my
head I can't even think of a franchise
and think like could this be in trouble
a mission impossible if you look at
Mission Impossible 7
um obviously great trailer you've got
Tom Cruise who's coming off of Maverick
it's going to be a huge hit next summer
but at the same time have we run the
course with Mission Impossible
um it feels more so the answer to that
is yes uh but you know Tom Cruise puts
his heart and soul into every film and
he can't help but like the guy so I
imagine it'll be still a winning enough
film but for me I still want to see
something original I mean ultimately I'd
rather see a really good original film
that is self-contained and doesn't
require extra homework I can just watch
this film get caught up in this universe
this world that the director created the
writer director came up with this film
and I get lost there and I don't have to
do all the homework I can just watch
this film
um so I think that's where my head is
I'd rather watch One Singular vision of
a film that is start finish one thing
one project and not have to have like a
franchise I'm more into those things
why does Spider-Man do so well
Spider-Man no way home did did the
numbers it did almost 2 billion
worldwide because it delivered
everything that you want out of the film
and some people call it fan service fine
there's fans out there and they need to
be serviced I mean it's not a bad thing
again if it feels organic and it doesn't
feel forced if the fan service feels
like oh we just threw all this stuff in
here because we want to do it but it has
to have a purpose and I think no way
home is a very good film at delivering
what the audience wanted to see from
that film I mean everybody wanted to see
all three Spider-Man right and not only
did you get them you got them in a large
amount you expected them to be a cameo
right you expected both of them to come
back and Andrew and Toby to be in the
film for wow maybe five minutes but no
they're on the whole back half of that
film and that was a great very smart
move by Sony uh and Marvel is is
allowing them to be back because people
didn't just want a cameo they really
wanted them back and they now created a
universe where they can actually make
films with both of them again if they
really wanted to you've got the spider
verse you could do almost anything with
it now
um and top gun Maverick same thing same
same thing as no way home it gives the
audience exactly what they want and
there's nothing wrong with that
um again if it feels grounded organic
and doesn't feel forced and just thrown
in there to be thrown in there it feels
like it's actually part and really
legitimately deserves to be there like
top gun Maverick and lot like no way
home those are both 100 crowd-pleasing
home runs and there's nothing wrong with
giving the audiences exactly what they
want
why is Doctor Strange the best movie of
2022 so far
that's definitely not true that is 100
false uh doctor strange and the
Multiverse of Madness is definitely not
the best film of 2022 and for the
reasons we've discussed I mean listen
Doctor Strange feels like multiple
directors in here it feels like almost
like a test screen movie right where you
multiple audiences all said I like this
this let's put these things together it
doesn't feel cohesive there's no moments
in doctor strange that ping the top not
one uh Doctor Strange is definitely not
the best film of the year the best film
of 2022 thus far is a tie it is X tie
West horror film and it is top gun
Maverick and for the for the different
they're very different films but very
clearly it's about direction for both
for me it's Ty West there and it's
Kaczynski on Maverick anytime you have a
strong directorial footprint on a film
I'm gonna like it and that's probably
why I don't like Doctor Strange as much
as some no one by the way has said
Doctor Strange is the best film of the
year there's nobody if you if you have
said that re-evaluate all of your sin
cinematic decisions from here back
because there's no way that that's the
best film of the year no chance okay so
if direction is so important to you yeah
then let's talk about just quickly the
safety Brothers yeah oh God so you have
one film that you absolutely love Yeah
by the safety Brothers oh yeah which I I
would praise as well but you have
another one that I love
probably just as much which you say
needs to be fixed in some areas Okay so
good time is I mean listen if we're
gonna pick two safety brother films
obviously they're they're most the ones
they are the most well renowned for one
good time and two uncut gems uh good
time is is here Uncle James is here and
here's for a number of reasons one the
one of the big ones for good time is
I don't remember the last time I saw a
film that was it's about 90 minutes but
at the end of good time it's over and
you literally the credits start rolling
you're like oh my God the movie's over I
don't think I've ever had that feeling
where you expect the film to keep going
and it literally no no we're done he's
in the back of the squad car the movie's
finished it's tight it's dirty it's raw
it feels like raw New York conversely
when I go to uncut gems and I look at
that film there's so many things wrong
with uncut gems um I think for starters
the length the length is bloated it's
two hours right bring that to them 130
135 better film and here's how you do
that first of all I know you want to do
the mining stuff I get it I understand
you want to do the gem mining that goes
on the colonoscopy does not work okay I
would completely eliminate that is gone
from the film you can start with a
mining but you don't need to do the
colonoscopy okay that's out and I think
even if you don't even want to do the
mining you can even get rid of that the
film opens on Adam Sandler on his phone
which is where the film really brings in
right that's the start and I think if
you make that change that film is better
also the fact that the safety brothers
are huge NBA fans I get it Kevin Garnett
actually is very good in the film but
it feels like and with the weekend as
well that it's like hey we have these
people that are big and successful like
the weekend and or Kevin Garnett we gave
him a big part but the weekend like this
just because he wants to be in the film
let's put him in it doesn't fit
organically in the story it feels forced
it's like hey we need to put the weekend
in the movie right it's like let's put
the cameo in there but it's not really
needs to be there and I think the
safeties got lost from from uncut from
uh good time to uncut gems the saftis
got too much of like hey let's put more
in our film when remember it all comes
back to less is more and that's why for
me good time it's not even a contest if
you go back and clean up the things I
said about uncut gems I think it's
actually all there the film uncut gems
is there it needs to be literally carved
down and then you're gonna get a film
that's better that's those are the worst
films too when you see a film that has
the elements all there and you have
extra pieces strapped on that don't
service the movie as well as they should
and or frankly aren't needed that brings
your film down it's like wow I can't
believe you actually brought your film
lower you lowered your film
by doing more less is more almost always